Shure: yes
Shure: Yes
Jake: 开始吧开始吧
Jake: Let's start, let's start.
Shure:  能对一下那什么吗
Shure: Can we check that thing?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Jake: 大家互相看一下谁的红灯
Jake: Everyone, look around and see whose red light is on.
Jake: 白灯没有亮就是
Jake: If the white light is off, then...
Lucia: 亮了吗
Lucia: Is it on?
Katrina: 亮了
Katrina: It's on.
Shure: 都亮了
Shure: They're all on.
Jake: 亮了很亮很亮
Jake: It's on, very bright, very bright.
Jake: 来看一会
Jake: Let's look for a while.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake: 好看吗
Jake: Is it nice?
Shure:  好看
Shure: It's nice.
Shure:  太棒了
Shure: It's awesome.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Nice.
Alice: 好看
Alice: Nice.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Nice.
Shure:  来给AI喂点抖音
Shure: Let's feed some TikTok to the AI.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 自己想看
Tasha: Wants to watch it himself.
Jake:评论评论评论
Jake: Comment, comment, comment.
Jake: 这谁啊
Jake: Who is this?
Shure: 陈泽啊
Shure: It's Chen Ze.
Jake:说你整我呢
Jake: Says you're messing with me.
Jake: 天天小考
Jake: Daily quizzes.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Jake:哎呦 卧槽
Jake: Oh gosh, damn it.
Jake:沙雕
Jake: Idiot.
Shure: 成谢谢您
Shure: Thanks a lot.
Jake: 好好嘞
Jake: Alright, alright.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Shure:  掉出来了
Shure: It fell out.
Jake: 哎呀怎么掉出来了
Jake: Oh no, how did it fall out?
Shure:  哎
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Katrina: 呀好热呀
Katrina: Oh, it's so hot.
Katrina:  感觉比武汉还热呀
Katrina: Feels hotter than Wuhan.
Jake: 会是老板第一个下车
Jake: The boss will be the first to get off.
Jake: 一般老板是第一个下车吗
Jake: Is the boss usually the first to get off?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Lucia: 不是应该先
Alice:公主请下车哎呦
Alice: Princess, please get off the car... Ouch!
Lucia: 司机先下车
Lucia: The driver should get off first.
Lucia: 然后给你把门拉开这种
Lucia: Then open the door for you, like this.
Tasha: 浪费下车
Tasha: Waste of getting off.
Jake: 不会第一个下车
Jake: He won't be the first to get off.
Shure:  万一遇刺什么的是吧
Shure: What if there's an assassination or something, right?
Jake: 对第一个下车第一个被崩
Jake: Yeah, the first one to get off is the first to get hit.
Shure: 第一个下了之后喽
Shure: After the first one gets off...
Shure:  保镖
Shure: Bodyguards.
Jake: 怎么过去啊
Jake: How do we get over there?
Jake: 怎么停在这么个地方啊
Jake: Why did we stop at this place?
Katrina: 怎么过去
Katrina: How do we get over?
Tasha: 跨过去
Tasha: Jump over.
Shure: 我们只要
Shure: We just need to...
Jake: 你跨一下
Jake: You jump over.
Shure: 助跑一下
Shure: Take a running start.
Lucia: 助跑一下哈哈哈
Lucia: Take a running start, hahaha.
Shure:  迟到了
Shure: We're late.
Shure:  这怎么给停这地方
Shure: Why did we stop at this place?
Shure:  给差评
Shure: One-star review.
Jake: 咋整啊
Jake: What should we do?
Jake: 那边是可以走吗
Jake: Can we walk over there?
Shure: 过去
Katrina:  盒马在这个商场里吗
Katrina: Is Hema in this mall?
Jake:那那那过得去吗
Jake: Can we get over there?
Jake: 过不去
Jake: No, we can't.
Tasha: 盒马在哪
Tasha: Where's Hema?
Shure:  啊从那过去
Shure: Ah, go from there.
Jake: 问问吧盒马那个有点高是吧
Jake: Let's ask, Hema is a bit further, right?
Shure: 盒马
Shure: Hema.
Shure:  师傅那个盒马鲜生在哪
Shure: Sir, where is Hema Fresh?
Shure:  从从这边绕过去是吗
Shure: Go around from this side, right?
Shure:  好的
Shure: Got it.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Jake: 这个行人还得这么绕
Jake: This pedestrian has to go around like this?
Lucia: 哎不是
Lucia: Hey, wait.
Lucia: 等一下同志们
Lucia: Wait a minute, guys.
Lucia: 腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: The long-legged people have already gone over.
Lucia: 呵呵是这是是是
Lucia: Haha, yes, that's it.
Shure:  这这边绕一下吧
Shure: Let's go around here.
Shure:  还是
Shure: Or
Katrina: 这边过去
Katrina: Let's go this way.
Shure:  对走吧走吧
Shure: Yeah, let's go, let's go.
Jake: 头盔要不给他吧
Jake: Should we give him the helmet?
Jake: 他跑过了
Jake: He already ran past.
Lucia: 哈哈腿长的人已经先过去了
Lucia: Haha, the long-legged ones already went ahead.
Katrina: 这能过去吗
Katrina: Can we get through here?
Jake: 跑过了他们
Jake: He ran past them.
Shure: 拉倒吧
Shure: Forget it.
Shure:  走吧走吧
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Jake: 你也要去
Jake: Are you going too?
Lucia: 不行我今天穿这衣服我翻不了
Lucia: No way, I can't climb in this outfit today.
Shure:  就这就能过去
Shure: Just this way and we can get through.
Katrina:  当时我们主要是十一点门禁
Katrina: At that time, we mainly had an 11 PM curfew.
Jake:下次一定
Jake: Next time for sure.
Katrina:  他会把那个东门的小门关了
Katrina: He would close the small gate at the east gate.
Katrina:  我们也这样翻进去
Katrina: We also climbed in this way.
Katrina:  保保安就看着我们翻
Katrina: The security just watched us climb.
Shure:  外面大门没有门禁
Shure: The main gate outside doesn't have a curfew.
Shure:  只有宿舍楼有门禁
Shure: Only the dormitory building does.
Katrina:  那小门他会关离我们宿舍进那个
Katrina: He would close that small gate near our dorm.
Katrina:  然后走那个大门要绕学校外面一圈
Katrina: Then to use the main gate, we had to go around the school.
Katrina:  他刚好有个那个放外卖的桌子 一起
Katrina: There was just a table for takeout, together.
Shure:  直接啪的一声
Shure: Just a loud smack.
Shure:  好快啊
Shure: So quick.
Katrina: 直接落地
Katrina: Landed straight down.
Katrina:  稳稳落地
Katrina: Landed smoothly.
Shure: 来轩导
Shure: Come on, Director Xuan.
Shure:  带路吧
Shure: Lead the way.
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where are they?
Shure:  轩导献过血吗
Shure: Director Xuan, have you donated blood?
Katrina: 啥
Katrina: What?
Shure: 献过血吗
Shure: Have you donated blood?
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
Katrina:  献过
Katrina: 大一献过
Katrina: I donated in my freshman year.
Tasha: 我的钻石掉了
Tasha: My diamond fell off.
Katrina: 我靠那针可粗了
Katrina: Wow, that needle was huge.
Katrina:  好高好呀
Katrina: So tall, so high.
Katrina:  献的300毫升
Katrina: I donated 300 milliliters.
Shure: 我也献过我献过两次
Shure: I've donated before, I've done it twice.
Jake: 补一个
Jake: Add one more.
Katrina:  然后差点抽晕
Katrina: And almost fainted.
Shure: 我200毫升就是
Shure: I did 200 milliliters.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Right.
Shure:  100就不流了你知道吗
Shure: At 100, it just stopped flowing, you know?
Alice:不闪了
Alice: It stopped flashing.
Katrina:  对就不流
Katrina: Yeah, it just stopped.
Katrina:  然后害怕你这样倒着你知道吗
Katrina: Then I got scared, you know, lying down.
Katrina:  倒着你要捏那个球啊
Katrina: You have to squeeze that ball while lying down.
Shure: 捏那个哎呀
Shure: Squeeze that, oh man.
Lucia: 啊你们在说什么献血吗
Lucia: Oh, are you guys talking about blood donation?
Katrina: 献血
Katrina: Blood donation.
Shure: 献血
Katrina:  当时就献100毫升
Katrina: I only donated 100 milliliters.
Katrina:  献不出来了
Katrina: And then it stopped.
Katrina:  然后医生就捏那个血
Katrina: Then the doctor squeezed the blood.
Shure:  然后旁边跟我一起去的那个
Shure: Then the guy who came with me...
Shure:  是一个小胖子
Shure: Was a chubby guy.
Shure:  啪嚓一分钟完事了
Shure: Done in a minute, just like that.
Alice:这吧
Alice: Really?
Shure:  啥事没有
Shure: No problem at all.
Shure:  下来了
Shure: He was done.
Katrina: 他说到了嗯到了
Katrina: He said it was done, yeah.
Shure:  然后看着我在这躺着
Shure: And then he saw me lying there.
Jake: 他们已经上去了
Jake: They already went up.
Shure:  哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh, oh.
Lucia: 进吧哎
Lucia: Come on in.
Lucia: 那个妹子哦
Lucia: That girl...
Lucia: 她在系鞋带
Lucia: She's tying her shoelaces.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  我俩给你敞开了大门
Shure: We opened the door wide for you.
Katrina:  谢谢
Katrina: Thanks.
Jake: 他们是上去了
Jake: They went up.
Lucia: 他们过来是不是还待一会
Lucia: Are they coming back soon?
Lucia: 那就先进去了
Lucia: Let's go inside first.
Shure:  他们选择什么
Shure: What did they choose?
Shure: 他们选择翻墙是吗
Shure: Did they decide to climb over the wall?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 什么情况
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 你们怎么已经到了啊
Lucia: How did you guys get here already?
Jake: 我们还找你们呢
Jake: We were looking for you!
Jake: 怎么丢了呀
Jake: How did you get lost?
修硕；没事
Katrina:  系了个鞋带而已
Katrina: Just tied a shoelace.
Shure:  我们我们跟着轩导的步伐来着
Shure: We were following Xuan's lead.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh right.
Jake: 殊途同归
Jake: Different paths, same destination.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  柯达照相
Katrina: Kodak photo.
Shure:  我们之前去那nar的时候买了一次性的胶圈
Shure: We bought a disposable camera last time we went to Nar.
Katrina:  哦我之前也想买
Katrina: Oh, I wanted to buy one before too.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Like,
Katrina:  我以为我们宿舍毕业旅行会去就
Katrina: I thought we’d get one for our dorm's graduation trip.
Alice:买一套工具自己做
Alice: Buy a kit and make it yourself.
Katrina:  新疆那地方就打算买一个
Katrina: Planning to buy one when we go to Xinjiang.
Tasha: 早知道不翻了
Tasha: Shouldn't have climbed over.
Alice: 这翻掉了
Alice: This was a fail.
Katrina:  我特别喜欢那种感觉那拍出来的
Katrina: I really love the feeling of those photos.
Shure: 真的特别好我靠
Shure: They turned out really great, wow.
Katrina:  那你有冲洗出来吗还是直打
Katrina: Did you get them developed or just digital?
Alice:看啥呢
Alice: What are you looking at?
Shure: 洗出来了已经
Shure: Already developed them.
Shure: 啊没没洗成那什么
Shure: Ah no, didn't develop well.
Katrina: 就是导出电子版是吧
Katrina: Just exported them digitally, right?
Shure: 对弄电子版然后再是胶片
Shure: Yeah, made digital copies first, then film.
Shure: 就是你透过阳光是能看到那个影子的
Shure: When you look through the sunlight, you can see the shadows.
Katrina:  好浪漫啊
Katrina: So romantic!
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Tasha: 然后有几根是那样很
Tasha: Then a few of them were like really...
Shure:  花活特多
Shure: Really artistic.
Shure:  然后我们俩就去两天
Shure: Then we just went for two days.
Shure: 一人背个大音箱一人背把吉他
Shure: One of us carried a big speaker, the other a guitar.
Katrina:  真好你俩soulmate呀
Katrina: That's awesome, you two are soulmates!
Jake: 这是啥地方
Jake: Where is this place?
Alice: 找到一双长睫毛的大眼睛哎
Alice: Found a pair of big eyes with long lashes.
Alice: 找到了在那
Alice: Found it, over there.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow
Alice: 哎让ai来一下
Alice: Hey, let AI take a look
Lucia: 不好意思又踩到你了
Lucia: Sorry, I stepped on you again
Shure:  哎呦sorry sorry
Shure: Oh, sorry, sorry
Katrina:  海澜之家
Katrina: HLA
Katrina:  海澜之家就在我们家旁边
Katrina: HLA is right next to our house
Tasha: 在甜甜圈中找到一块饼干
Tasha: Find a cookie in the donut
Lucia: 甜甜圈中找到一块饼干
Lucia: Find a cookie in the donut
Alice:哦在哪
Alice: Oh, where?
Shure: 海澜之家男人的衣柜
Shure: HLA, a man's wardrobe
Jake: 这得多瞎啊
Jake: How blind do you have to be?
Jake: 他看不到啊
Jake: He can't see it
Alice: 还有呢
Alice: What else?
Alice: 怎么有股有毒的味道
Alice: Why does it smell toxic?
Tasha: 用这个眼镜去测试你看
Tasha: Use these glasses to test, look
Tasha: 做测试这
Tasha: Do the test here
Lucia: 感觉刚装修完似得
Lucia: Feels like it was just renovated
Tasha: 在车站中找到海澜之家
Tasha: Find HLA at the station
Alice: 哦原来在这等着我们呢
Alice: Oh, it's waiting for us here
Alice: 软广
Alice: Product placement
Tasha: 还真没找着
Tasha: Really couldn't find it
Lucia: 在衬衫中找到海
Lucia: Found HLA in the shirt
Shure: 真的在用心的找诶
Shure: Really looking hard
Jake: 怎么找啊
Jake: How to find it?
Jake: 海澜之家是啥啊
Jake: What's HLA?
Alice:海澜之家
Alice: HLA
Lucia: 就是一个卖男装的品牌
Lucia: It's a men's clothing brand
Jake: 海澜之家
Jake: HLA
Jake:那他是什么
Jake: What's that?
Katrina: 海澜之家的总工厂就在我们家旁边的镇上
Katrina: The main factory of HLA is in the town next to us
Jake: 找他的logo吗
Jake: Looking for its logo?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: Don't know
修硕;是吗
Shure: Really?
Katrina: 江阴市
Katrina: Jiangyin city
Katrina: 二楼
Katrina: Second floor
Jake:都不知道要找什么
Jake: Don't even know what to look for
Shure:  你再往往那边走走
Shure: You go that way
Tasha: 难度可能是进阶的
Tasha: The difficulty might be advanced
Katrina: 海澜之家
Katrina: HLA
Alice: 他可能就是
Alice: He might be...
Jake:他应该
Jake: He should
Katrina: 他那个集团还养马就是那老板喜欢马
Katrina: Their group also raises horses because the boss likes horses.
Alice: 为了给你留下一个深刻的印象
Alice: To leave a deep impression on you.
Tasha: 然后就一直在找海澜
Tasha: Then just kept looking for Hailan.
Katrina: 他就运那种很贵很贵的马过来我靠一匹马几百万
Katrina: He transports those very expensive horses, like, one horse costs millions.
Jake:对一个一个找
Jake: Yes, find them one by one.
修硕；哇靠
Shure: Wow.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Is that so?
Jake: 所以应该长啥样
Jake: So what should it look like?
Katrina: 然后我们之前初中就会去参观
Katrina: We used to visit it when we were in middle school.
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Jake: 海澜之家是自己有个logo是长这样吗
Jake: Does Hailan Home have its own logo that looks like this?
Katrina: 海澜的马场
Katrina: Hailan's horse farm.
修硕；哇靠
Shure: Wow.
Jake: 还是啥呀
Jake: Or what?
Alice: 海澜之家
Alice: Hailan Home.
Lucia: 他logo长啥样啊
Lucia: What does their logo look like?
Alice: 我就记得一个h一个l他们家的门面
Alice: I just remember an 'h' and an 'l' on their storefront.
Jake:他logo长啥样不知道哇
Jake: I don't know what their logo looks like.
Katrina: 就是我们那个市还挺厉害的
Katrina: Our city is quite impressive.
Katrina:  他们家的是还是挺厉害的
Katrina: Their place is actually pretty amazing.
Lucia: 啊好像是
Lucia: Ah, it seems so.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Katrina:  就是无锡下面那个江阴市
Katrina: It's Jiangyin City under Wuxi.
Lucia: 不了解因为因为咱们平常也不买男装
Lucia: I don't know because we usually don't buy men's clothes.
Katrina:  因为因为我从来不买男装
Katrina: Because I never buy men's clothes.
Katrina: 他就去年自己通了高铁所以我直接
Katrina: They got their own high-speed rail last year, so I directly
Alice: 里面就是没有我感觉都一样
Alice: Inside, it all feels the same to me.
Jake: 对我也不买男装
Jake: Yeah, I don't buy men's clothes either.
Shure: 买刮刮乐吗
Shure: Do you buy scratch cards?
Katrina: 直接南京到那里
Katrina: Directly from Nanjing to there.
Katrina: 刮刮乐
Katrina: Scratch cards.
Tasha: 那他穿什么
Tasha: Then what does he wear?
Alice:怪怪的
Alice: That's weird.
Jake: 就这个哈哈哈哈
Jake: This one, hahaha.
Lucia: 女装
Lucia: Women's clothes.
Lucia: 淘宝T恤啊你穿
Lucia: Taobao T-shirts, yeah, you wear those.
Shure: shoppingshopping
Shure: Shopping, shopping.
Tasha: 你看喜茶标志很明显
Tasha: Look, the Heytea logo is very obvious.
Katrina: shoppingshopping
Katrina: Shopping, shopping.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 这个确实哎
Jake: This is indeed true.
Lucia: 那可能是上面确实有个标志只是没找到
Lucia: Maybe there really is a sign up there, we just couldn't find it.
Shure:  我猜到了
Shure: I guessed it.
Shure:  因为我也想喝这个
Shure: Because I also want to drink this.
Tasha: 还测吗哈哈
Tasha: Are we still testing? Haha.
Alice: 这有一股有毒的味道
Alice: There's a toxic smell here.
Alice: 感觉在这闻久了要晕倒
Alice: I feel like if we stay here too long, we'll pass out.
Lucia: +1
Lucia:有种没装修完的
Lucia: It feels like it's not fully renovated.
Tasha: 是两位男生推购物车吗
Tasha: Are the two guys pushing the carts?
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 推两辆是吗
Tasha: Pushing two carts, right?
Tasha: 一一边采购酒一边采购食材是吗
Tasha: One for buying alcohol and one for buying groceries, right?
Jake: 呃啊酒要单独一个车吧
Jake: Uh, alcohol should have its own cart.
Lucia: 哎那还有小的
Lucia: Oh, there's a smaller one.
Jake: 推个小的
Jake: Push a small one.
Lucia: 还有小的
Lucia: There's a smaller one.
Lucia: 啊太小了推起来不好推
Lucia: Ah, it's too small, hard to push.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 有那个小把手
Tasha: It has a little handle.
Katrina: 这
Katrina: This...
Lucia: 这就是小孩推的意思吗
Lucia: Is this meant for kids to push?
Jake: 哦是
Jake: Oh, yes.
Lucia: 是把小孩放在里面推小孩的意思吗
Lucia: Does it mean putting a kid inside and pushing them?
Tasha: 是让小孩推这个车的意思
Tasha: It means kids are supposed to push it.
Alice:是让小孩推得
Alice: It's meant for kids to push.
Jake: 小孩应该也进不去
Jake: Kids probably can't even fit in there.
Jake: 这得是
Jake: It has to be...
Lucia: 不会是把小孩放在里面
Lucia: You wouldn't put a kid inside.
Jake:猫
Tasha: 这这小孩坐这
Tasha: This, this, kids sit here.
Jake: 请
Jake: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Tasha: 谁
Tasha: Who?
Jake: 都行啊
Jake: Anyone works.
Shure:  我能上吗
Shure: Can I get on?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 算了
Shure: Never mind.
Jake: 给你推货
Jake: I'll push the goods for you.
Jake: 给你推冰柜去
Jake: I'll push the freezer for you.
Jake: 就那个水产
Jake: For the seafood section.
Tasha: 西瓜
Tasha: Watermelon.
Alice:西瓜
Alice: Watermelon.
Tasha: 买二得三
Tasha: Buy two, get three.
Alice: 榴莲怎么这么便宜
Alice: Why is durian so cheap?
Alice: 是不是该下了
Alice: Should we get it?
Tasha: 有人不爱吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Does anyone not like durian?
Jake: 我可以吃
Jake: I can eat it.
Alice:没有吧
Alice: Really?
Lucia: 不是很爱
Lucia: Not really a fan.
Shure:  怎么说咱们是分头行动
Shure: So, are we splitting up?
Lucia: 但没事你想吃的话
Lucia: But it's okay if you want to eat it.
Shure:  还是一起行动
Shure: Or are we moving together?
Shure:  你把那个图po到那里吧
Shure: Post that picture over there.
Jake: 我们有分工吗
Jake: Do we have separate tasks?
Katrina: 发群里吗
Katrina: Post it in the group?
Jake: 我们分几个路啊
Jake: How many routes do we have?
Shure: 对图po群里
Shure: Yes, post the picture in the group.
Alice: 分几个路啊
Alice: How many routes do we have?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Jake: 其实我们戴着这个眼镜
Jake: Actually, with these glasses on,
Jake: 绕着一圈就重建了
Jake: Walking around once will recreate everything.
Jake: 就是这个整个商场商场就3D重建了
Jake: The entire mall will be reconstructed in 3D.
Tasha: 场景
Tasha: Scene.
Shure: 所以那天
Shure: So, that day...
Jake: 就一个赛博盒马
Jake: It's like a cyber Hema.
Shure:  让我哈哈哈
Shure: Made me laugh out loud.
Tasha: 没有网哎 你记得吗
Tasha: There's no internet, remember?
Jake: 每个角落走一圈
Jake: Walk around every corner.
Katrina: 我发了
Katrina: I posted it.
Shure:  会怎么样
Shure: What will happen?
Katrina: 那就分
Katrina: Then let's split up.
Katrina:  分其实5-10就是你们买菜啊
Katrina: Actually, splitting up into 5-10 groups means you guys buy groceries.
Katrina:  生活用品的那种地方
Katrina: In the place with daily necessities.
Katrina:  可以你们那就分两拨
Katrina: You guys can split into two groups.
Tasha: 那就5-11呗
Tasha: Then it'll be 5-11.
Jake: 分两拨分两拨
Jake: Split into two groups, split into two groups.
Katrina: 分两拨
Katrina: Split into two groups.
Tasha:  5-11
Tasha: 5-11.
Katrina:  5-11跟1-4
Katrina: 5-11 and 1-4.
Tasha: 你是1-4和12对吗
Tasha: You're 1-4 and 12, right?
Katrina:  啊可以可以
Katrina: Ah, sure, sure.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  1-4和12
Katrina: 1-4 and 12.
Katrina:  走我俩去哪个
Katrina: Let's go, which one are we going to?
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What's this?
Jake: 这是这是什么组
Jake: What group is this?
Jake: 这是什么组
Tasha: 这是食材组
Tasha: This is the ingredients group.
Katrina: 我我去
Katrina: I'll go.
Katrina:  我们俩去买酒吧
Katrina: We two will go buy wine.
Tasha: 这是酒组
Tasha: This is the wine group.
Jake: 酒组行行好
Jake: Wine group, okay, okay.
Katrina:  那你们还要一个过来不
Katrina: Do you need one more person?
Katrina:  12123456 我俩再加一个
Katrina: 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. We two will add one more.
Lucia: 珊珊好了那就
Lucia: Shanshan, okay then.
Katrina:  33
Katrina: Three, three.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina: 他肯定要
Katrina: He definitely wants to.
Jake: 行那怎么说
Jake: Alright, so what do we say?
Jake:对食材
Jake: Yes, for the ingredients.
Katrina:  他是你们的主主星
Katrina: He's your main star.
Katrina:  组合里你俩选
Katrina: In the group, you two choose.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Alice: 我我我跟他绑定
Alice: I, I, I'm with him.
Lucia: 我都都行
Lucia: I'm fine with anything.
Lucia: 那我来好了
Lucia: Then I'll do it.
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿嘿好
Tasha: Hehe, okay.
Katrina:  好反正你还比较懂调酒
Katrina: Alright, you still know more about mixing drinks.
Katrina:  那我们去买酒吧
Katrina: Then let's go buy wine.
Tasha: 对你们三个都是懂酒的
Tasha: Yeah, you three know about wine.
Lucia: 也没有那么
Lucia: Not that much.
Lucia: 我我我没有那么懂了其实
Lucia: I, I, I don't actually know that much.
Jake: 确实我是一点都不懂
Jake: Honestly, I don't understand at all.
Jake: 我咖啡都不喝
Jake: I don't even drink coffee.
Katrina:  朗姆
Katrina: Rum.
Jake: 都没法买啥也没法
Jake: I can't buy anything, nothing at all.
Katrina: 冰块模具
Katrina: Ice cube molds.
Jake: 但是好像食品
Jake: But it seems like food...
Shure: 盒马的酒我想想啊
Shure: Let me think about Hema's alcohol...
Jake: 我也不懂
Jake: I don't know either.
Lucia: 我可以申请买个水果
Lucia: Can I request to buy some fruit?
Shure: 他会在一个中间的一个
Shure: He'll be in the middle...
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Buy it.
Tasha: 想吃什么你可以跟我说啊
Tasha: If you want to eat something, just let me know.
Shure: 柜子上
Shure: On the shelf.
Lucia: 随便只要是个水果就行
Lucia: Anything, as long as it's fruit.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha really.
Katrina:  我要那个青提
Katrina: I want those green grapes.
Katrina:  阳光玫瑰那种
Katrina: The Shine Muscat ones.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 好那我那我也吃这个就可以了
Lucia: Alright, I'll have those too.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Katrina:  你的青梅青梅啊
Katrina: Your green plums, green plums, huh?
Tasha: 啊这个会买的
Tasha: Ah, this one will be bought.
Katrina:  青梅啊啊
Katrina: Green plums, ah.
Tasha: 您觉得买一盒还是买两盒呢
Tasha: Do you think we should buy one box or two?
Jake: 买买哎我看看啊
Jake: Buy, buy, let me see.
Tasha: 我觉得可以买两盒
Tasha: I think we can buy two.
Tasha: 一盒做蛋糕一盒也吃
Tasha: One box for making cakes, one box to eat.
Shure: 这个来公共场合现在已经不感觉到羞耻了
Shure: Coming to public places now doesn't feel embarrassing anymore.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Katrina:  是的
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  我们都是那种视力矫正的没关系
Katrina: We all have vision correction, it's fine.
Alice:这个长得不好换一个
Alice: This one doesn't look good, change it.
Jake: 是不是买两盒
Jake: Should we buy two boxes?
Jake: 两盒都吃了呀
Jake: Eat both boxes?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没事他们不知道这个是干啥用的
Lucia: It's okay, they don't know what this is for.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: This one then.
Alice: 这个大
Alice: This one's big.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 你们可以商量商量
Jake: You guys can discuss it.
Jake: 为什么选这个
Jake: Why choose this one?
Katrina: 还有那果汁
Katrina: And that juice too.
Tasha: 这个草莓好吃
Tasha: These strawberries are delicious.
Jake: 不是就是为什么这个
Jake: No, I mean why this one?
Alice: 因为这个有白的感觉没有很
Alice: Because this one looks whiter and doesn't feel...
Tasha: 他这个要买
Tasha: He wants to buy this one.
Alice:饱满成熟
Alice: Full and ripe.
Tasha: 你看他这个虽然小但他多
Tasha: Look, although it's small, there are more of them.
Tasha: 这个虽然大但他少
Tasha: This one is big but there are fewer of them.
Alice: 他多吗
Alice: Are there more?
Tasha: 对对这个是多两排这个是少两排的
Tasha: Yes, this one has two more rows, this one has two less.
Tasha: 我经常吃
Tasha: I eat them often.
Tasha: 对，他少两排
Tasha: Yes, this one has two less rows.
Alice:啊没发现
Alice: Ah, I didn't notice.
Shure: 应该就在那吧 等一下
Shure: It should be over there, wait a moment.
Tasha: 他少两排
Tasha: It has two less rows.
Tasha: 你看你没事
Tasha: Look, you're fine.
Alice:诶一排还是两排啊
Alice: Hey, is it one row or two rows?
Jake: 他这个他这个挡着
Jake: This one, this one is blocking it.
Jake: 是有还是没有啊
Jake: Does it have it or not?
Tasha: 呃有
Tasha: Uh, it does.
Alice: 哦这是5排这是6排
Alice: Oh, this one has 5 rows, this one has 6 rows.
Lucia: 我们主要就是一些饮料吗
Lucia: We're mainly looking for some drinks, right?
Tasha: 呃就是一排两排
Tasha: Uh, it's just one row, two rows.
Jake:哦没那么狗是吧
Jake: Oh, it's not that stingy, right?
Shure: 这都是啤酒不是洋酒
Shure: These are all beers, not spirits.
Katrina: 嗯有朗姆酒了问直接问是吧
Katrina: Hmm, there's rum, should we just ask directly?
Tasha: 这是一排两排三排四排对对
Tasha: This is one row, two rows, three rows, four rows, yes.
Lucia: 要不问问他们
Lucia: Should we ask them?
Alice: 哦嗯那么要大的还是要小的呢
Alice: Oh, hmm, so do we want the big ones or the small ones?
Tasha: 那肯定要大的
Tasha: Of course, we want the big ones.
Alice:大的吧
Alice: The big ones, right.
Katrina:  你好
Katrina: Hello.
Shure: 洋的在哪呢
Shure: Where are the spirits?
Katrina:  请问这里有郎酒吗
Katrina: Excuse me, do you have Langjiu here?
Tasha: 这就是他们刚刚点名的
Tasha: This is the one they just mentioned.
Alice: 阳光玫瑰
Alice: Sunshine Rose.
Shure: 啊成谢谢您
Shure: Ah, got it, thank you.
Alice: 找一个果形饱满的
Alice: Find one with a full shape.
Lucia: 好谢谢 啊sorry
Lucia: Okay, thank you. Ah, sorry.
Tasha: 我觉得这个比较多
Tasha: I think this one has more.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 都500克吧
Alice: They're all 500 grams, right?
Tasha: 但好像都是500克
Tasha: But it seems they're all 500 grams.
Lucia: 招牌烤鸡
Lucia: The signature roast chicken.
Tasha: 那我选他吧
Tasha: Then I'll choose this one.
Tasha: 你觉得呢
Tasha: What do you think?
Tasha: 你有没有心仪的
Tasha: Do you have a favorite?
Alice: 我觉得长得都差不多
Alice: I think they all look the same.
Tasha: 那这个吧
Tasha: Then this one.
Alice: 他们家评论还可以
Alice: The reviews for this place are pretty good.
Jake: 我看看这都多少钱
Jake: Let me check how much all these are.
Tasha: 不能吃现切的
Tasha: You can't eat freshly cut ones.
Jake: 我看看都多少钱
Jake: Let me check how much they are.
Jake: 我就看一眼
Jake: I'll just take a look.
Jake: 多少钱我比比价
Jake: I'll compare the prices.
Jake: 为什么不能吃现切的
Jake: Why can't you eat freshly cut ones?
Tasha: 因为你没听过前段时间现切的事吗
Tasha: Haven't you heard about the freshly cut stuff recently?
Shure: 这就是朗姆
Shure: This is rum.
Tasha: 把坏的切掉把好的然后
Tasha: They cut off the bad parts and keep the good ones.
Jake: 好的就在这卖了
Jake: They sell the good ones here.
Shure: 够了这
Shure: That's enough.
Jake: 坏的就在这卖了
Jake: They sell the bad ones here.
Katrina: 够了是吧主要加一点点
Katrina: Is that enough? Just add a little bit more.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure:  咱咱从今天开始喝喝最后一天都喝不完
Shure: If we start drinking today, we won't finish even by the last day.
Jake: 给世界人民涨涨知识
Jake: Let's educate the people of the world.
Tasha: 还有什么让我们看一看
Tasha: What else can we see?
Tasha: 水果采购
Tasha: Fruit shopping.
Tasha: 蓝莓要吗
Tasha: Do we need blueberries?
Katrina: 你觉得嘞还要吗
Katrina: What do you think? Do we need them?
Jake:蓝莓可以要
Jake: We can get blueberries.
Alice: 蓝莓在门口那个大果
Alice: There's a big blueberry at the entrance.
Katrina: 可以买小一点的
Katrina: We can buy smaller ones.
Lucia: 对如果有小就是小瓶的话
Lucia: Yeah, if they have smaller bottles.
Lucia: 我们就可以买两种
Lucia: We can get two kinds.
Shure: 小皮小便宜小瓶对
Shure: Small bottles, small price, right?
Lucia: 对但是感觉看起来好像
Lucia: Yeah, but it looks like...
Shure:  但其实你买3个小瓶
Shure: But if you buy three small bottles...
Alice: 需要凤梨吗
Alice: Do we need pineapples?
Shure: 就跟这个一个大瓶
Shure: Just like this big bottle
Tasha: 你喜欢吃可以拿一盒
Tasha: If you like it, you can take a box
Shure: 就那种他有卖50毫升50毫升那么小的
Shure: They also sell small ones, like 50ml each
Alice:我觉得一般
Alice: I think it's just okay
Lucia: 哦那种小小的
Lucia: Oh, those small ones
Tasha: 我也觉得一般
Tasha: I also think it's just okay
Lucia: 就是酒板那么小那种
Lucia: Like those small bottles
Alice:有没有买了几种啊
Alice: Did you buy a few kinds?
Katrina: 诶有的那种便利店有是不是就是这种小小的
Katrina: Yeah, some convenience stores have those small ones
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Alice: 这个是用来吃的
Alice: This one is for eating
Lucia: 对但是那种太小了
Lucia: Yes, but those are too small
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes
Alice: 这个是用来摆的
Alice: This one is for display
Tasha: 这个也可以用来摆
Tasha: This one can also be for display
Alice: 再加一个黄的
Alice: Add a yellow one
Lucia: 如果没有的话我觉得我们买一瓶popular cutting就可以了
Lucia: If they don't have it, we can just buy a bottle of popular cutting
Tasha: 黄的芒果
Tasha: Yellow mango
Alice:芒果
Alice: Mango
Lucia: 不然也喝不完
Lucia: Otherwise, we can't finish it
Katrina: 维他
Katrina: Vita
Jake:菠萝
Jake: Pineapple
Alice: 芒果
Alice: Mango
Katrina: get
Katrina: Got it
Tasha: 菠萝不太好放在甜品里
Tasha: Pineapple doesn't go well in desserts
Jake: 甜品来尝尝
Jake: Try it in a dessert
Alice: 买这个吧
Alice: Let's buy this one
Shure:  维他柠檬茶
Shure: Vita lemon tea
Alice:这个他们家的
Alice: This is from their brand
Alice:那种
Alice: That kind
Tasha: 可以呀
Katrina:  这喝了确实有点瘾
Katrina: It is kind of addictive
Katrina: 喝了又想喝
Katrina: You drink it, you want more
Jake: 不是不能现切吗
Jake: Can't they cut it fresh?
Shure: 白熊
Shure: Polar bear
Katrina:  还要买可乐
Katrina: We also need to buy cola
Jake: 到底能不能现切
Jake: Can they cut it fresh or not?
Lucia: 对可乐可怜
Lucia: Yes, poor cola
Tasha: 其实我觉得现切的不太好
Tasha: Actually, I think fresh cut isn't that good
Tasha: 你可以买那个让他帮你现场切
Tasha: You can buy that and have them cut it on the spot.
Katrina: 这好像饮料都在这一块
Katrina: Seems like all the drinks are in this area.
Jake: 那可以啊
Jake: That works.
Jake: 但是买凤梨不是不是
Jake: But buying a pineapple is... no, no.
Lucia: 这里有气泡酒吗气泡酒
Lucia: 酒精度数会低一点
Lucia: The alcohol content is a bit lower.
Katrina: 气泡酒只有RIO那边
Katrina: Sparkling wine is only at the RIO section.
Jake:放不放甜点里
Jake: Should we put it in the dessert?
Tasha: 不放
Tasha: No.
Jake: 啊就自己吃
Jake: Ah, we'll just eat it ourselves.
Shure: 你说那种香槟那种是吗
Shure: You mean like champagne, right?
Alice: 拿一个吧
Alice: Grab one.
Jake:好让他切吧
Shure: 买吧
Shure: Let's buy it.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh, wow.
Jake: 给他拍一个特写一个切的
Jake: Get a close-up of him cutting it.
Katrina: 是要买这么多吧
Katrina: Are we buying this much?
Jake: 可乐
Jake: Cola.
Tasha: 你看他可以呼叫店员帮你切
Tasha: You see, you can call the staff to help you cut it.
Lucia: 可乐我们买瓶装还是听装
Lucia: Should we buy bottled cola or canned cola?
Jake: 好切
Jake: Okay, cut it.
Katrina:  你说买这个大的哇他才4块8哎
Katrina: You're saying buy this big one? It's only 4.8 yuan, wow.
Tasha: 挑的话挑那种刺比较尖的
Tasha: When picking, choose the one with sharper spikes.
Lucia: 就是听装的话如果打开没有喝完就还可以盖上
Lucia: If it's canned, you can still cover it if you don't finish it.
Katrina: 果粒橙咱有是吧
Katrina: We have pulpy orange juice, right?
Jake: 挑比较大格子比较大
Jake: Pick the one with bigger grids.
Jake: 这个我会
Jake: I know this.
Lucia: 对果粒橙咱还有剩了多少两个半瓶
Lucia: Yeah, how much do we have left? About two and a half bottles.
Jake: 这个我在新加坡
Jake: I did this in Singapore.
Jake: 这个我在新加坡切过
Jake: I cut this in Singapore.
Shure: 两个半瓶对
Shure: Two and a half bottles, yes.
Lucia: 相当于一整瓶大概
Lucia: That's about one whole bottle.
Tasha: 你觉得这两个哪个好
Tasha: Which of these two do you think is better?
Shure: 一整瓶
Shure: One whole bottle.
Jake:这个我看看
Jake: Let me see this one.
Lucia: 但是可能喝不到最后一天是吧
Lucia: But we might not finish it by the last day, right?
Katrina:  这个才是主要是
Katrina: This is the main thing.
Alice:还有点扎呢
Alice: It's still a bit prickly.
Katrina:  如果开了的话
Katrina: If it's opened...
Katrina:  如果这两天想喝开了到后来就没气了
Katrina: If you open it these two days, it will lose its fizz later on.
Alice:这个是不是更熟
Alice: Is this one more cooked?
Jake:这个吧
Jake: This one, maybe.
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Katrina: 买小瓶吧
Katrina: Let's buy a small bottle.
Alice: 绿不拉几差不多吧
Alice: The green one looks about right.
Alice: 差不多这个吧
Alice: This one seems fine.
Shure:  嗨反正公款
Shure: Oh well, it's on the company account anyway.
Jake: 看谁胖一点哇
Jake: Let's see who's fatter.
Jake:这个吧就这个吧
Jake: This one, let's go with this one.
Alice: 您好
Alice: Hello.
Jake: 您好
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 切，谢谢您
Jake: Okay, thank you.
Shure:  可以买点橙汁什么的
Shure: We can buy some orange juice or something.
Katrina:  椰汁
Katrina: Coconut juice.
Shure:  橙汁也好喝
Shure: Orange juice is tasty too.
Katrina: 椰汁是不是只能打开放一天啊
Katrina: Doesn't coconut juice spoil after a day?
Jake: 这就下班了
Jake: We're off work already?
Jake: 这才几点
Jake: What time is it?
Jake: 那我们现在谁跟我说来着
Jake: So who told me that just now?
Shure: 好像是
Shure: Seems like it.
Katrina: 谁跟我说来着不能过夜
Katrina: Who told me it can't stay overnight?
Lucia: 不知道哎好久没买椰汁了
Lucia: I don't know, haven't bought coconut juice in a while.
Jake: 就不让我们切
Jake: They just won't let us cut it.
Shure: 弄一瓶
Shure: Get a bottle.
Jake: 我们没有收钱哦
Jake: We didn't take any money, you know.
Katrina:  想喝就拿吧
Katrina: If you want to drink, just take it.
Tasha: 那他什么时候开始切
Tasha: When will he start cutting it?
Shure: 就是平常大家也喝
Shure: People usually drink it.
Lucia: 如果买橙汁了
Lucia: If we buy orange juice...
Lucia: 我们一会就
Lucia: We'll just...
Lucia: 挑一个气泡酒吧
Lucia: Pick a sparkling wine later.
Katrina:  可以呀
Katrina: Sounds good.
Katrina:  这样就可以调柠檬茶了
Katrina: That way we can make lemon tea.
Katrina: 都行啊
Katrina: Anything works.
Tasha: 行吧那我们买个这个吧
Tasha: Alright, let's buy this one then.
Lucia: 拿一个也行吧
Lucia: Grabbing one is fine.
Katrina:  大瓶的怕都喝中毒了
Katrina: If we get a big bottle, we might get poisoned.
Tasha: 你挑一个
Tasha: You pick one.
Jake: 行吧那就至于大家信他一个吧
Jake: Alright, let's trust him with this one then.
Tasha: 买一个这个才8块钱
Tasha: Buying this one is just 8 yuan.
Tasha: 我觉得小台芒是芒果里面最甜的
Tasha: I think the small Thai mango is the sweetest among all mangos.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 你挑挑哪个
Tasha: You pick one.
Katrina: 北冰洋
Katrina: Beibingyang (a brand).
Tasha: 是6个的啊
Tasha: It's a pack of six.
Tasha: 我刚看到这个是6个但他这有霉点
Tasha: I just saw this pack of six, but it has mold spots.
Lucia: 对这的话
Lucia: Yeah, about that...
Tasha: 所以要挑一个
Tasha: So we need to pick...
Tasha: 另一个6个的
Tasha: Another pack of six.
Katrina: 这是葡萄酒
Katrina: This is wine.
Alice:小台芒的吗
Alice: Is it small Thai mangos?
Tasha: 发挥你的眼睛对
Tasha: Use your eyes to pick, yes.
Lucia: 雷司令甜度会更高一些
Lucia: Riesling is sweeter.
Shure: 这就是气泡酒
Shure: This is sparkling wine.
Alice: 小台芒比较甜比较软
Alice: Small Thai mangos are sweeter and softer.
Tasha: 对小台芒
Tasha: Yes, small Thai mangos.
Shure:  起泡酒
Shure: Sparkling wine.
Jake:这是6个吗
Jake: Is this a pack of six?
Lucia: 对这个是起泡酒
Lucia: Yes, this is sparkling wine.
Shure:  最后一天开瓶香槟
Shure: Pop champagne on the last day.
Shure:  好吧卧槽
Shure: Alright, damn.
Lucia: 这个其实也没有很贵吧
Lucia: This isn't very expensive, right?
Tasha: OK看看水果就买齐了吧
Tasha: Okay, let's see if we've bought all the fruits.
Shure: 对98而已
Shure: Yeah, only 98.
Tasha: 下一步是
Tasha: Next step is...
Lucia: 这个是这个是
Lucia: This one, this one.
Tasha: 牛奶无菌蛋牛奶
Tasha: Milk, sterile eggs, and milk.
Lucia: 底下是红葡萄酒
Lucia: The bottom is red wine.
Lucia: 就这一种气泡酒啊
Lucia: This is the only sparkling wine.
Shure:  上面也是
Shure: The top too.
Lucia: 上面这个是蒙耶
Lucia: The top one is Monier.
Lucia: 蒙耶的山东就是这个
Lucia: Monier from Shandong is this one.
Alice:这是你外送的
Alice: This is your delivery.
Lucia: 很贵的吧应该
Lucia: It should be expensive, right?
Shure: 没有188
Shure: No, it's 188.
Jake: 对我在拍他
Jake: Yeah, I'm filming it.
Lucia: 哦旁边这比较贵
Lucia: Oh, the one next to it is more expensive.
Lucia: 对哈哈
Lucia: Yes, haha.
Jake: 给个特写
Jake: Give it a close-up.
Shure: 不行就这个吧
Shure: If not, then this one.
Lucia: 我们能不能
Lucia: Can we...
Katrina: 够了平时也可以喝嘛
Katrina: That's enough, we can drink it anytime.
Lucia: 如果如果大家觉得OK的话可以试试
Lucia: If everyone thinks it's OK, we can try it.
Alice:这款还挺好喝的
Alice: This one actually tastes pretty good.
Shure: 对这个其实其实度数很低
Shure: Yeah, this one actually has a really low alcohol content.
Tasha: 我我也觉着
Tasha: I, I also think...
Lucia: 因为起泡
Lucia: Because sparkling...
Lucia: 因为起泡酒加那个柳橙汁
Lucia: Because sparkling wine with orange juice...
Lucia: 是很经典的一款鸡尾酒
Lucia: It's a classic cocktail.
Tasha: 椰子水拿一瓶吧
Tasha: Let's grab a bottle of coconut water.
Katrina: 拿下
Katrina: Got it.
Tasha: 但在哪呢
Tasha: But where is it?
Lucia: 如果大家想试试可以试试
Lucia: If everyone wants to try, we can try it.
Alice:椰子水买那个吧
Alice: Let's buy that coconut water.
Katrina: 拿下拿下
Katrina: Got it, got it.
Tasha: 这个哎这个
Tasha: This one, hey, this one...
Shure: 公款吃喝天呐这辈子能有几回啊
Shure: Eating and drinking on public funds, oh my, how many times in a lifetime can you do this?
Tasha: 这个贵了一点
Tasha: This one is a bit expensive.
Shure:  而且连着七天吃喝家人们
Shure: And for seven consecutive days, my friends.
Tasha: 买这个
Tasha: Buy this one.
Alice: 这个就是那个便宜的
Alice: This is the cheap one.
Tasha: 这个是便
Tasha: This one is cheap.
Shure: 啊不行这是不都记住了我靠
Shure: Ah, no, this won't do, remember this, damn it.
Tasha: 是便宜的啊
Tasha: It's cheap, huh.
Tasha: 他们都是一升
Tasha: They are all one liter.
Alice: 这怎么是8块9了
Alice: How is this 8.9 yuan?
Tasha: 对他们都是一升
Tasha: Yeah, they are all one liter.
Lucia: 没事他们应该会把这一段剪掉的放心吧
Lucia: No worries, they should cut this part out, don't worry.
Tasha: 但他只要8块9
Tasha: But it's only 8.9 yuan.
Tasha: 他还更贵
Tasha: It's even more expensive.
Lucia: 我猜的
Lucia: I'm just guessing.
Katrina:  结束了杨老板才看
Katrina: Jake will only see it after it's over.
Alice: 果汁哦
Alice: Juice, oh.
Alice: 果汁是他们买
Alice: The juice is bought by them.
Shure: 杨老板我明天就带着眼镜跑路
Shure: Jake, I'll run away with my glasses tomorrow.
Tasha: 还有东西吗
Tasha: Is there anything else?
Shure:  想吃吗牛奶
Shure: Do you want milk?
Tasha: 牛奶无菌蛋
Tasha: Milk and sterile eggs.
Alice: 牛奶买了吗
Alice: Did we buy milk?
Shure: 我卖眼镜直接倒手一卖
Shure: I'll sell my glasses and flip them for a profit.
Tasha: 牛奶买了
Tasha: Got the milk.
Alice: 两盒够不够
Alice: Are two boxes enough?
Tasha: 够了吧
Tasha: Should be enough.
Shure: 8000美刀
Shure: 8000 dollars.
Alice:无菌蛋
Alice: Sterilized eggs.
Tasha: 鸡蛋鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs, eggs.
Shure: 而且还是属于商密这种
Shure: And it's still considered confidential.
Shure: 就是还没开放的版本
Shure: It's the unreleased version.
Jake:淡奶油在什么地方
Jake: Where's the whipping cream?
Tasha: 淡奶油在
Tasha: The whipping cream is...
Jake:在很里边吗
Jake: Is it deep inside?
Shure: 一万美刀我靠
Shure: 10,000 dollars, damn.
Alice: 奶油应该在酸奶这边
Alice: The cream should be near the yogurt section.
Alice: 是差不多的地吧
Alice: It's probably around there.
Lucia: 这眼镜不是你有一万美刀也不一定能买得到嘛
Lucia: These glasses, even with 10,000 dollars, you might not be able to buy them.
Tasha: 我觉得差不多在冰柜这里
Tasha: I think it's around the freezer section.
Lucia: 好像他只给高校
Lucia: Seems like they only provide them to universities.
Lucia: 就是分发一些用来做实验
Lucia: Like distributing them for experiments.
Jake: 要不问问他嘞
Jake: How about we ask him?
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 哈哈谈话内容逐渐危险
Lucia: Haha, the conversation is getting dangerous.
Shure:  刚是不是还说买个桃汁
Shure: Weren't we talking about buying peach juice earlier?
Tasha: 你好淡奶油在哪里有
Tasha: Excuse me, where can I find the whipping cream?
Shure:  会员那个桃汁哦
Shure: The member-exclusive peach juice.
Tasha: 哪里
Tasha: Where?
Jake: 你这有淡奶油卖吗
Jake: Do you sell whipping cream here?
Katrina:  遇到了
Katrina: Ran into him.
Katrina:  boss
Katrina: Boss.
Tasha: 只有喷射的吗
Tasha: Only the spray kind?
Jake: 您家哦还不是一家
Jake: Oh, you guys don't have it here?
Katrina: 饮料这也有
Katrina: There are drinks here too.
Lucia: 试试吧
Lucia: Let's give it a try.
Tasha: 好谢谢啊
Tasha: Okay, thanks.
Jake: 哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Lucia:  哈喽
Lucia: Hello.
Alice: 安佳的吗
Alice: Is it Anchor?
Shure:  你平时喝酒吗
Shure: Do you usually drink?
Tasha: 是的但他比网上还贵
Tasha: Yeah, but it's more expensive than online.
Lucia: 你问我们俩的谁
Lucia: Who are you asking, the two of us?
Lucia: 里面的谁
Lucia: Which one of us inside?
Shure: 你们俩
Shure: You two
Tasha: 他没有嗯
Tasha: He didn't, um
Jake: 我来瞅瞅你们买的啥
Jake: Let me take a look at what you bought
Shure: 平时喝酒吗
Jake: 你们看起来进度一般了
Jake: You don't seem to be making much progress
Katrina:  嗯没找到饮料
Katrina: Hmm, couldn't find any drinks
Shure:  是要我们大买特买那个意思吗
Shure: Are you saying we should buy a lot?
Lucia: 他买了椰子水
Lucia: He bought coconut water
Lucia: 刚好我们不用买了啊
Lucia: So we don't need to buy it
Katrina:  哦他们买了椰子水
Katrina: Oh, they bought coconut water
Katrina:  是要用椰奶还是椰子水啊
Katrina: Should we use coconut milk or coconut water?
Lucia: 呃其实最好是椰奶
Lucia: Uh, actually, it's best to use coconut milk
Lucia: 但是咱们也没有那么那个啥嘛
Lucia: But we're not that picky, right?
Lucia: 那么抠细节
Lucia: We're not that detailed
Shure:  椰奶和椰子水完全两个味啊
Shure: Coconut milk and coconut water taste totally different
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah
Tasha: 我暂时还不在你
Tasha: I'm not with you right now
Lucia: 再自己加一点
Lucia: Add a bit more yourself
Katrina:  我刚说饮料肯定有一点的
Katrina: I just said there should be some drinks
Shure: 肯定有椰奶
Shure: There must be coconut milk
Tasha: 要不明天再
Tasha: Or we can get it tomorrow
Shure: 盒马的东西还是比较全养乐多
Shure: Hema's stuff is usually pretty complete, like Yakult
Tasha: 我明天再去拿行吗
Tasha: I'll get it tomorrow, okay?
Katrina:  养乐多
Katrina: Yakult
Katrina:  养乐多要买两排吧
Katrina: Should we buy two packs of Yakult?
Tasha: 好谢谢
Tasha: Okay, thanks
Katrina:  这感觉我们自己偷偷喝都喝掉
Katrina: Feels like we'll drink it all ourselves
Shure:  买3排
Shure: Buy three packs
Katrina: 买3排
Katrina: Buy three packs
Shure:  这低糖的
Shure: This is low sugar
Alice: 选好了吗
Katrina:  低糖嗯
Katrina: Low sugar, hmm
Katrina:  图个心里
Katrina: Just for peace of mind
Shure:  有一次喝
Shure: Once I drank
Katrina:  味道差不多
Katrina: Tastes about the same
Shure:  喝养乐多兑那个那什么葡萄汁然后
Shure: Yakult mixed with grape juice and then
Tasha: 好吧价格差不多呢
Tasha: The price is about the same
Shure:  伏特加第二天进医院
Shure: Vodka, next day I ended up in the hospital
Katrina:  为什么啊
Katrina: Why?
Alice: 买两个
Alice: Buy two
Shure:  就急性肠胃炎
Shure: Just acute gastroenteritis.
Shure:  我可能就是
Shure: I might just...
Tasha: 你看网上才卖12块五
Tasha: Look, it's only 12.50 online.
Shure: 略微有一点乳糖不耐
Shure: Slightly lactose intolerant.
Shure:  然后再加上那两天
Shure: And then those days...
Alice: 是这家的吗
Alice: Is it from this store?
Tasha: 是这个
Tasha: Yes, this one.
Shure: 变天就是气候变化特别大
Shure: The weather changed drastically.
Jake:奶油找着了吗
Jake: Did you find the cream?
Alice: 但是它的包装不一样
Alice: But the packaging is different.
Tasha: 好吧它是安佳
Tasha: Okay, it's Anchor.
Jake:就这个
Jake: It's this one.
Tasha: 它是雀巢
Tasha: It's Nestle.
Alice: 安佳会比较贵
Alice: Anchor is more expensive.
Katrina: 葡萄汁呢我直接问他吧
Katrina: How about grape juice? I'll just ask him.
Tasha: 贵了10块钱一瓶
Tasha: It's 10 yuan more expensive per bottle.
Shure:  然后之后就闻到那个养乐多味道就开始ptsd
Shure: After that, whenever I smell Yakult, I start getting PTSD.
Tasha: 如果说这一瓶可以做6个纸杯蛋糕的话
Tasha: If one bottle can make 6 cupcakes...
Alice: 我们得做多少个
Alice: How many do we need to make?
Tasha: 6个太贵了
Tasha: 6 is too expensive.
Tasha: 这120块钱我觉得就要大差大要
Tasha: 120 yuan, I think we should get...
Tasha: 买先买4瓶吧
Tasha: Let's buy 4 bottles first.
Jake: 啊咱是一伙的我们觉得这不够
Jake: Ah, we're in this together, and we think it's not enough.
Alice: 我们这个现在在网上买还来的及吗
Alice: Can we still buy this online in time?
Tasha: 也可以吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Jake: 太少了还有多的吧
Jake: Too few, there's more, right?
Jake: 这种类太少了
Jake: This kind is too few.
Tasha: 蓝风车
Tasha: Blue Windmill.
Katrina:  汇源果汁也没看见
Katrina: I didn't see Huiyuan juice either.
Jake:那行吧谢谢您
Jake: Alright then, thank you.
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh...
Shure:  都在酒水那边吗
Shure: Is everything in the drinks section?
Jake: 这还能小时达吗还是明天达
Jake: Can this be delivered within an hour or by tomorrow?
Tasha: 是啊我要看看嘛
Tasha: Yeah, I need to check.
Shure:  我们真的按计划来的吗
Shure: Are we really following the plan?
Shure:  p人哎不是j人
Shure: It's P people, not J people.
Katrina:  是在买这些啊
Katrina: Are we buying these?
Jake:你这可以选的诶
Jake: You can choose these.
Shure:  我们要不买点火锅底料
Shure: Should we buy some hotpot base?
Shure:  然后哪天晚上整一顿吧
Shure: And have a hotpot night sometime?
Tasha: 一件
Tasha: One piece.
Katrina: 也可以
Katrina: That's fine too.
Lucia: 对咱那天说吃火锅来
Lucia: Yeah, we said we'd have hot pot.
Lucia: 就今天中午
Lucia: This afternoon.
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure thing.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 说哪天做火锅来着
Lucia: When did we say we'd have hot pot?
Shure:  这清单卖的东西j人
Shure: Does this list have everything we need?
Shure:  能买吗
Shure: Can we buy it?
Katrina:  可以可以哈哈哈
Katrina: Sure, sure, hahaha.
Shure:  我主要怕你结账时候崩溃
Shure: I just worry you'll freak out at checkout.
Shure:  你们为什么买清单外的东西
Shure: Why are you buying stuff not on the list?
Katrina:  有预算的话肯定就不行
Katrina: If we have a budget, then we can't.
Katrina: 或者说预算不需要我考虑
Katrina: Or maybe I don't need to worry about the budget.
Tasha: 你看他这个小时达的哎
Katrina:  你们是不是有人不能吃辣呀
Katrina: Does anyone here not eat spicy food?
Tasha: 五棵松店呀
Tasha: The Wukesong store?
Tasha: 就这个
Tasha: Just this one.
Shure: 菌汤的那个然后再来个牛油的
Shure: The mushroom soup one, then the beef oil one.
Alice: 你知道五颗松在哪吗
Alice: Do you know where Wukesong is?
Tasha: 不知道呵呵
Tasha: No idea, haha.
Katrina:  鸳鸯锅哦
Katrina: The yin-yang pot, oh.
Tasha: 我选的地址可能在那哦
Tasha: I might have picked the address there.
Shure:  咱们没有鸳鸯锅耶
Shure: We don't have a yin-yang pot.
Katrina:  也那搞两锅呗
Katrina: Let's just get two pots then.
Lucia: 科松在
Lucia: Wukesong is...
Shure:  搞两个6个人搞两个锅
Shure: Two pots for six people.
Lucia: 在我学校呢
Lucia: Near my school.
Katrina:  有有两个锅吗
Katrina: Do we have two pots?
Shure:  啊有
Shure: Yeah, we do.
Shure:  那肯定有
Shure: Definitely.
Lucia: 在另一边
Lucia: It's on the other side.
Shure:  随便拿一个
Shure: Just grab one.
Jake: 我帮你拿
Jake: I'll help you.
Shure:  这一看就很牛逼的样子
Shure: This one looks pretty cool.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure:  就拿这个
Shure: Let's take this one.
Jake: 不用谢
Jake: No problem.
Shure:  走
Shure: Let's go.
Alice: 这好可爱这是什么
Alice: This is so cute, what is it?
Lucia: 如果少了可能还要再买
Lucia: If we run out, we might need to buy more.
Jake: 那就网上买
Jake: Then just buy it online.
Lucia: 渴吗
Lucia: Thirsty?
Shure: 希望你们不要背着我偷偷吃火锅
Shure: I hope you guys aren't secretly having hotpot without me.
Jake:行啊可以网上下个单呗
Jake: Sure, we can place an order online.
Shure: 不要今晚吃好吗
Shure: Can we not eat it tonight?
Jake: 不要紧啊
Jake: It's fine.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake:然后下单
Jake: And then place the order.
Lucia: 如果22号的那天的话可以先在网上买
Lucia: If it's for the 22nd, we can buy it online first.
Lucia: 今晚应该来不及吃放心吧
Lucia: We won't have time to eat it tonight, don't worry.
Jake:22号那一天
Jake: On the 22nd.
Tasha: 不是说那天要做蛋糕吗
Tasha: Didn't we say we're making a cake that day?
Alice:还早嘛
Alice: It's still early.
Shure:  没看到
Shure: Didn't see it.
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks.
Jake: 厉害你这个
Jake: You're good at this.
Jake: 这戴个帽子就把头发挡住了
Jake: Just wear a hat and it covers your hair.
Tasha: 然后要什么来着
Tasha: What else do we need?
Alice: 对无菌蛋
Alice: Yeah, sterile eggs.
Shure:  鸡蛋
Shure: Eggs.
Shure:  那就买那个盒马的桃汁也一样
Shure: Let's also buy that peach juice from Hema.
Tasha: 鸡蛋
Tasha: Eggs.
Katrina:  他们是不是有什么
Katrina: Do they have something?
Tasha: 糖盐
Tasha: Sugar and salt.
Shure: 买点苏打水
Shure: Buy some soda water.
Katrina: 品牌利益
Katrina: Brand benefits.
Shure: 然后苏打苏打水然后和那什么
Shure: And then soda water and what else.
Tasha: 奶粉咖啡冻奶油薄荷保鲜膜
Tasha: Milk powder, coffee, whipped cream, mint, plastic wrap.
Shure: 就一个道理的
Shure: It's the same logic.
Tasha: 蛋挞皮草莓
Tasha: Tart crusts, strawberries.
Katrina: 苏打水和什么
Katrina: Soda water and what?
Tasha: 美文纸为什么也是我们买
Tasha: Why are we buying the beautiful paper too?
Tasha: 金针菇3-4个
Tasha: Enoki mushrooms, 3-4 pieces.
Shure: 苏打水和葡萄汁那不就是
Shure: Soda water and grape juice, isn't it.
Tasha: 松花蛋娃娃菜
Tasha: Century eggs, baby bok choy.
Shure:  元气森林吗
Shure: Yuanqi Forest?
Tasha: 记住了吗
Tasha: Got it?
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake: 娃娃菜走
Jake: Baby bok choy, let's go.
Jake: 哈哈你哈哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, you hahaha
Tasha: 诶鸡蛋
Tasha: Hey, eggs
Lucia: 可乐味
Lucia: Cola flavor
Alice:无菌蛋吗
Alice: Sterilized eggs?
Tasha: 买鸡蛋送松花蛋
Tasha: Buy eggs, get preserved eggs
Tasha: 刚好哎
Tasha: Perfect timing
Jake: 诶刚好啊
Jake: Hey, just right
Tasha: 是无菌的吗
Tasha: Are they sterilized?
Katrina:  啊这是胡萝卜跟葡萄算了
Katrina: Ah, this is carrots and grapes, forget it
Alice: 鲜鸡蛋吧
Alice: Fresh eggs then
Katrina: 这有点
Katrina: This is a bit
Shure: 其实一样
Shure: Actually, it's the same
Tasha: 啊鲜鸡蛋也可以吧
Tasha: Ah, fresh eggs are fine too
Katrina: 葡萄味道在里面
Katrina: The grape flavor is in it
Jake: 你们家离高邮远吗
Jake: Is your home far from Gaoyou?
Jake: 高邮
Jake: Gaoyou
Shure: 那你买那个美汁源的那个葡萄汁
Shure: Then buy that Master Kong grape juice
Jake: 啊你们家离那远
Jake: Ah, is your home far from there?
Alice: 高邮鸭蛋哦
Alice: Gaoyou salted duck eggs
Katrina: 美汁源他说没有啊盒马没有美汁源
Katrina: Master Kong, they said there's none, Hema doesn't have Master Kong
Alice: 咸鸭蛋
Alice: Salted duck eggs
Tasha: 不远
Tasha: Not far
Tasha: 不远不远
Tasha: Not far, not far
Tasha: 你们家也不远啊
Tasha: Your home isn't far either
Shure: 不还有果粒橙嘛
Shure: Isn't there still Minute Maid with pulp?
Katrina:  哦不是说错了
Katrina: Oh, no, I said it wrong
Jake:啊对确实
Jake: Ah, right, indeed
Katrina:  没有汇源
Katrina: No Huiyuan
Alice: 哦那个是可生食的哦
Alice: Oh, that one is edible raw
Katrina: 买它这是桑葚这也不是葡萄
Katrina: Buy this, this is mulberry, it's not grapes
Tasha: 这呢我觉得可生食的买一点就行了
Tasha: This one, I think the edible raw ones are fine, just buy a bit
Katrina: 葡萄汁呢
Katrina: What about grape juice?
Tasha: 然后再买一盒这个也可以了
Tasha: And then buy a box of this, that’s fine too
Alice: 行啊
Alice: Sure
Shure: 把 j人掰直随便拿
Shure: Just grab whatever you want
Tasha: 这个就买
Tasha: Just buy this one
Shure: 就这个一样的
Shure: This one is the same
Tasha: 呃做那个提拉米苏
Tasha: Uh, making tiramisu
Katrina: 但他有胡萝卜的味道诶
Katrina: But it has a carrot flavor
Alice:提拉米苏用
Alice: Tiramisu use
Tasha: 对然后别的都可以用
Tasha: Yes, and everything else can be used.
Tasha: 用非无菌的蛋
Tasha: Using non-sterile eggs.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 熟的就行
Alice: As long as they're cooked, it's fine.
Shure: 没事不好喝就干喝了吧
Shure: No worries, if it tastes bad, just drink it straight.
Jake: 无菌蛋无菌蛋是什么意思
Jake: What does sterile egg mean?
Tasha: 无菌蛋就是你现在直接可以吃下去
Tasha: A sterile egg is one you can eat directly now.
Jake: 就是他为什么叫无菌蛋
Jake: Why is it called a sterile egg?
Tasha: 因为有
Tasha: Because it has...
Tasha: 因为他就是不会有细菌吧
Tasha: Because it doesn't have bacteria, I guess.
Tasha: 可能
Tasha: Maybe.
Alice:是什么沙门氏菌什么的
Alice: Like Salmonella or something?
Shure: 哪有苏打水
Shure: Where's the soda water?
Jake: 他就是这个鸡比较牛逼
Jake: It's because the chicken is pretty amazing.
Shure: 苏打水
Shure: Soda water.
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Alice: 就是他的那个饲养流程比较那啥
Alice: It's just that the feeding process is quite strict.
Alice: 控制比较严
Alice: They control it pretty tightly.
Jake: 刚生下来然后就被保存起来了之类的
Jake: Right after it's laid, it's preserved immediately or something.
Shure: 椰奶这不是椰奶
Shure: Coconut milk, this isn't coconut milk.
Alice: 具体的不是很清楚
Alice: Not really sure about the details.
Tasha: 无菌蛋牛奶白糖盐
Tasha: Sterile eggs, milk, white sugar, salt.
Lucia: 这个不是太大了吗
Lucia: Isn't this too big?
Alice: 调味料那边
Alice: The seasonings are over there.
Alice: 哦那边是蔬菜
Alice: Oh, those are the vegetables.
Katrina:  我靠他两罐起卖
Katrina: Wow, you have to buy at least two cans?
Alice: 买点菌菇类的
Alice: Get some mushrooms and such.
Lucia: 就是为什么会两罐起卖啊
Lucia: Why do we have to buy at least two cans?
Katrina: 买一送一吗
Katrina: Is it buy one, get one free?
Tasha: 哇这是什么茶
Tasha: Wow, what kind of tea is this?
Lucia: 我尝一下
Alice: 黄瓜花也能吃吗
Alice: Can you eat cucumber flowers?
Katrina:  可瓦达是用椰汁还是是用椰奶
Katrina: Is Kawada made with coconut water or coconut milk?
Shure:  这什么水啊 9.3ph
Shure: What kind of water is this? 9.3 pH.
Jake: 买 买
Jake: Buy it, buy it.
Shure: 快问快答ph9.3是
Shure: Quick question, quick answer. Is pH 9.3...
Alice: 为什么娃娃菜这么贵
Alice: Why is baby cabbage so expensive?
Jake:你要买吗
Jake: Do you want to buy it?
Shure:  碱性还是酸性
Shure: Is it alkaline or acidic?
Katrina:  我没学化学
Katrina: I didn't study chemistry.
Jake:高山鲜
Jake: High mountain fresh.
Katrina: 我从高二就没学化学
Katrina: I haven't studied chemistry since sophomore year.
Alice: 没有普通的吗
Alice: Don't you have a regular one?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Alice: 找找别的啊
Alice: Look for something else then.
Katrina:  我是最后一年江苏卷
Katrina: I was the last year for the Jiangsu exam.
Tasha: 老板你有想吃的吗
Tasha: Boss, do you have anything you want to eat?
Katrina:  我就考300多分
Katrina: I only scored over 300 points.
Alice: 这是大白菜啊
Alice: This is napa cabbage.
Shure:  满分多少500
Shure: What's the full score, 500?
Lucia: 似乎是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Katrina: 480
Katrina: 480.
Jake:我把我想吃的人都招过来了 会做吗
Jake: I've invited everyone I want to eat with. Can you cook?
Lucia: 按照网上的说的是椰奶
Lucia: According to the internet, it's coconut milk.
Tasha: 就买这个娃娃菜买了吗
Tasha: Did we buy this baby cabbage?
Jake:会做好吃的菜的人都招过来了
Jake: I've invited all the good cooks.
Jake: 这玩意他买了吗
Jake: Did he buy this thing?
Lucia: 椰奶或者椰浆的意思
Alice: 没有但是我感觉好贵啊他
Alice: No, but I feel like it's expensive.
Shure:  他是这个椰子牌椰汁我从小喝到大
Shure: This is the Coconut brand coconut juice I've been drinking since I was a kid.
Shure:  应该也可以
Shure: It should work too.
Tasha: 但是看着也挺好嫩的怎么这么贵去我家地里摘吧
Tasha: But it looks so tender, why is it so expensive? Let's pick from my garden.
Lucia: 应该也行那个感觉比较像椰浆
Lucia: It should be fine, that one feels more like coconut cream.
Lucia: 感觉比较大吧
Lucia: It feels bigger.
Alice: 主要是他一煮他就很小啦
Alice: The main thing is, it shrinks a lot when cooked.
Lucia: 椰汁应该那种比较清的是椰汁吧
Lucia: Coconut juice is usually the clear type, right?
Katrina: 冷藏区
Katrina: The refrigerated section.
Tasha: 那拿点上海青
Tasha: 上海青才一块钱哈哈
Tasha: Bok choy is only one yuan, haha.
Shure:  coffee
Shure: Coffee.
Alice: 但是他没那个味
Alice: But it doesn't taste the same.
Shure:  你是不是要coffee来着
Shure: Did you want coffee?
Alice: 让我找一下
Alice: Let me find it.
Alice: 要不然买成这个
Alice: Or should we buy this one?
Shure: 你买一条吧万一那什么呢
Shure: Buy a strip, just in case.
Alice: 我们我们可以我们把帮
Alice: We can, we can help.
Tasha: 也可以
Tasha: That works too.
Lucia: 可以我感觉我现在已经挺困的了
Lucia: Okay, I feel really sleepy now.
Jake: 为什么这个不行
Jake: Why won't this one work?
Alice: 因为那个比较贵
Alice: Because that one's more expensive.
Tasha: 这个多少钱
Tasha: How much is this?
Alice: 要不然我们
Alice: Or we could...
Jake:他为什么贵啊
Jake: Why is it so expensive?
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Katrina: 西柚味的话拿哪个代替啊
Katrina: What can we replace the grapefruit flavor with?
Alice: 白菜能贵到哪
Alice: How expensive can cabbage be?
Shure: 西柚这个也行
Shure: This grapefruit one is fine too.
Alice: 一千 1千克的话
Alice: One kilogram is...
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage.
Shure:  j人已经
Shure: Someone already...
Alice:姜
Alice: Ginger.
Shure:  快快那什么了
Shure: Hurry up with that.
Tasha: 没有价格怎么回事
Tasha: Why is there no price tag?
Shure:  快麻了
Shure: It's almost numb.
Shure:  所有的全是代替的
Shure: Everything is a substitute.
Shure:  除了养乐多
Shure: Except Yakult.
Lucia: 没关系我们可以调整一下计划
Lucia: No worries, we can adjust the plan.
Alice:这是杭白菜吗
Alice: Is this Hangzhou cabbage?
Tasha: 你去那扫个码就知道了
Tasha: Just scan the code over there and you'll know.
Shure: 都一个味咱就喝吧
Shure: If it all tastes the same, let's just drink it.
Katrina:  桃
Katrina: Peach.
Alice:这没没称
Alice: There's no scale.
Shure:  一喝一个不吱声
Shure: Drink it in one go and no one will complain.
Katrina:  一喝一个中毒啊
Katrina: Drink it in one go and get poisoned.
Shure:  这晚上你就试试
Shure: Try it tonight.
Katrina:  桃汁呢那
Katrina: Where's the peach juice?
Katrina:  哦那边还有一个
Katrina: Oh, there's another one over there.
Katrina:  感觉盒马也不是特别大哎
Katrina: Hema store doesn't seem that big.
Shure:  啊鸡蛋他们买了吗
Shure: Did they buy the eggs?
Katrina: 他们应该会买
Katrina: They probably did.
Shure:  生食鸡蛋这种
Shure: The raw eggs.
Lucia: 他们应该买了吧
Lucia: They should have bought them, right?
Alice: 这个5块钱哎
Alice: This is 5 yuan.
Lucia: 或许
Lucia: Maybe.
Lucia: 看到他们了
Lucia: I see them.
Jake: 那个十一块是吧
Jake: That one is 11 yuan, right?
Alice: 那个十一
Alice: That one is 11.
Alice: 并且两份也不太够
Alice: And two portions are still not enough.
Shure: 你们买鸡蛋了吗
Shure: Did you guys buy eggs?
Alice: 买个这个
Alice: Buy this one.
Shure:  你们买鸡蛋了吗
Shure: Did you guys buy eggs?
Jake: 买鸡蛋了
Jake: We bought eggs.
Jake: 买了无菌蛋
Jake: We got sterile eggs.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  我们买了两个火锅底料
Shure: We bought two hotpot bases.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hotpot bases.
Katrina: 没有桃汁啊
Katrina: There's no peach juice.
Shure:  完了我们j人崩溃了
Shure: Oh no, we're going to lose it.
Jake: 我们好像我们我们分到了个
Jake: It seems like we, we got...
Shure: 气的跳脚脚了
Shure: ...so mad we're jumping up and down.
Jake: 什么奇怪的任务来着
Jake: ...some weird task.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Shure: 扎死人
Shure: It's killing us.
Alice: 美纹纸
Alice: Masking tape.
Katrina: 普通的品牌都没有吗
Katrina: Not even any regular brands?
Jake:美纹纸美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: Masking tape, what's that?
Alice:美纹纸这有吗
Alice: Do they have masking tape here?
Katrina:  美文纸美文纸
Katrina: Masking tape, masking tape.
Lucia:美纹纸这这里面能买到吗
Lucia: Can we buy masking tape here?
Jake: 美纹纸是什么东西
Jake: What is masking tape?
Katrina: 就贴墙上不留痕的那贴纸
Katrina: It's the tape that doesn't leave marks on the wall.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 要不直接上网买吧
Katrina: Maybe just buy it online?
Alice:再买两个
Alice: Get two more.
Katrina: 跟那海报一起嘛嗯
Katrina: Buy them with the posters, yeah.
Katrina:  跟那个美纹纸很便宜
Katrina: And the masking tape is cheap.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 嗯啊我觉得文具店也会有
Tasha: Hmm, I think the stationery shop might have it too.
Katrina: 冰块模具还没买
Katrina: We haven't bought the ice cube molds yet.
Katrina:  但这有我们感觉全是买吃的地方
Katrina: But it feels like all we’ve bought is food.
Shure:  够呛呦冰块模具
Shure: Hard to find ice cube molds.
Katrina: 盒马是不是主营饮食啊
Katrina: Isn't Hema mainly a food store?
Alice:要不然我们买大白菜吧
Alice: How about we buy some cabbage?
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Shure: 对生鲜类
Shure: Yeah, fresh produce.
Alice:然后我们把嫩的部分给它扔进去
Alice: And we can throw the tender parts in.
Katrina: 那就直接叫美团外送吧
Katrina: Let’s just order from Meituan.
Tasha: 可以呀 可以
Tasha: Sure, sounds good.
Shure: 美团外送可以
Shure: Meituan delivery works.
Katrina: 冰块模具打孔器彩笔
Katrina: Ice cube molds, hole punchers, colored pens.
Shure:  或者直接美团买冰得了
Shure: Or we could just get ice from Meituan.
Katrina:  美团可以买冰吗
Katrina: Can you buy ice on Meituan?
Katrina: 他运过来不会化吗
Katrina: Won't it melt during delivery?
Shure:  可以的
Shure: It will be fine.
Alice:因为它比较沉
Alice: Because it's heavy.
Jake:跳舞了
Jake: Time to dance.
Alice:所以把它放下边
Alice: So put it at the bottom.
Alice:这样不会把它压坏
Alice: That way it won't get crushed.
Katrina:  柠檬片没买
Katrina: We didn't buy lemon slices.
Tasha: 哦这什么
Tasha: Oh, what's this?
Lucia: 是要那种
Lucia: Is it that kind...
Lucia: 就是加工过的柠檬片还是鲜柠檬那种
Lucia: ... of processed lemon slices or fresh lemons?
Alice:槐花你吃过吗
Alice: Have you ever eaten locust flowers?
Tasha: 吃春菜
Tasha: Spring vegetables.
Shure: 直接买柠檬然后切了就行咱们有刀
Shure: Just buy lemons and cut them, we have a knife.
Katrina: 直接买柠檬也行
Katrina: Buying lemons works too.
Shure:  先买柠檬
Shure: Buy lemons first.
Alice: 对槐花你吃过吗
Alice: Right, have you tried locust flowers?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice: 这可以炒可以做包子
Alice: You can stir-fry them or make buns.
Shure:  你看哎
Shure: Look, hey.
Alice:很好吃甜甜的
Alice: They are really delicious and sweet.
Shure:  什么来什么啊
Shure: What are you talking about?
Shure:  这是土豆啊
Shure: This is a potato.
Shure:  不好意思哈哈哈
Shure: Sorry, haha.
Alice:就是这个是一种可以吃的东西
Alice: It's just that this is something edible.
Katrina: 窝窝头是不是
Katrina: Is it a cornbread?
Tasha: 金针菇买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy enoki mushrooms?
Shure:  是窝窝头还是土豆
Shure: Cornbread or potatoes?
Alice: 买了买了
Alice: Bought them, bought them.
Jake:这为什么撒了呀
Jake: Why is this scattered?
Shure:  流心包
Shure: It's a molten bun.
Alice:从缝里掉出来了
Alice: It fell through the gap.
Tasha: 那你吃啊快别浪费
Tasha: Then eat it quickly, don't waste it.
Alice:不是这不能生吃
Alice: No, this can't be eaten raw.
Shure: 私密马赛
Shure: Smelly Marseille (a play on words).
Jake:哈哈哈下毒
Jake: Hahaha, poison.
Alice: 没事不要告诉他
Alice: It's okay, don't tell him.
Alice: 让他吃也行
Alice: Let him eat it, it's fine.
Katrina: 柠檬
Katrina: Lemon.
Jake:那他吃了会怎么样呢
Jake: What will happen if he eats it?
Shure: 柠檬肯定有
Shure: There must be lemon.
Alice: 不好吃
Alice: It tastes bad.
Lucia: 青柠
Lucia: Lime.
Jake:主要是不好吃是吧
Jake: Mainly it tastes bad, right?
Lucia: 这个是青柠檬吗
Lucia: Is this lime?
Katrina: 青柠更适合还是柠檬更适合
Katrina: Is lime better or lemon?
Tasha: 调味料还有胡椒粉味精盐
Tasha: The seasonings also include pepper, MSG, and salt.
Shure: 都来
Shure: Bring everything.
Lucia: 都还行哎
Lucia: Everything is fine.
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Tasha: 还有盐哎
Tasha: There's also salt.
Katrina: 哎爽快
Katrina: Ah, refreshing.
Alice:嗯得找一个专门那啥的
Alice: Hmm, we need to find a specialist.
Jake:槐花呀
Jake: Locust flower.
Katrina:  笑死
Katrina: So funny.
Lucia: 这才4块6啊
Lucia: It's only 4.6 yuan.
Alice:你吃过吗
Alice: Have you tried it?
Tasha: 豆芽豆芽就放在放一个清理
Tasha: Bean sprouts, just put it in, clean it.
Katrina: 这放这放饮品里是不是好喝
Katrina: Is it good to put this in a drink?
Jake:我感觉还真吃过
Jake: I think I've actually tried it.
Shure: 哦小小小小青柠吧
Shure: Oh, small small small lime.
Alice:豆芽不可以没啥味
Alice: Bean sprouts are flavorless.
Lucia: 整个放进去
Lucia: Put the whole thing in.
Katrina: 这好
Katrina: This is good.
Tasha: 够够够
Tasha: Enough, enough.
Lucia: 然后普通青柠就跟你们一样切片
Lucia: Then just slice the regular lime like you guys.
Shure:  lemon
Shure: Lemon.
Shure:  哎wonder
Shure: Hey, wonder.
Shure:  i wonder why
Shure: I wonder why.
Alice:葱姜蒜
Alice: Green onions, ginger, garlic.
Tasha: 葱姜蒜超市不送
Tasha: The supermarket doesn't deliver green onions, ginger, garlic.
Katrina:  彩笔打孔器这玩意会有吗
Katrina: Will they have colored pencil sharpeners?
Jake:啊超市不送
Jake: Ah, the supermarket doesn't deliver?
Tasha: 会送吧怎
Tasha: They should, right?
Jake:怎么送啊
Jake: How do they deliver?
Tasha: 要葱姜蒜吗
Tasha: Do you want green onions, ginger, garlic?
Shure:  打孔器采纸这种
Shure: Hole punchers, paper stuff.
Shure:  文具的应该这都没有
Shure: Stationery items, they don't have these.
Jake:就就我们买这些东西他就会送葱姜蒜
Jake: If we buy these things, they will deliver green onions, ginger, garlic.
Katrina: 那冰块
Katrina: Those ice cubes
Lucia: 那些实在不行
Lucia: They really won't work
Lucia: 感觉在淘宝上买也来得及
Lucia: I feel like we can still buy them on Taobao
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah
Tasha: 够吗他送的
Tasha: Is it enough what he sent?
Katrina: 这是干什么的
Katrina: What's this for?
Katrina: 打包吗他们在
Katrina: Are they packing it?
Tasha: 我只是觉得他会送
Tasha: I just think he'll send it
Alice:葱怎么卖啊
Alice: How much is the green onion?
Jake:我我我我我
Jake: Me, me, me, me, me
Katrina: 那就没了
Katrina: Then it's all gone
Katrina: 我们就主要采购酒的东西
Katrina: We're mainly shopping for the drinks
Alice:蒜
Alice: Garlic
Jake:surprise闻所未闻
Jake: Surprise, never heard of it
Katrina: 那看看还有啥想吃的买
Katrina: Then see if there's anything else we want to buy
Jake:shocked
Jake: Shocked
Tasha: 真的假的不是
Tasha: Really, not?
Jake:不不知道
Jake: Don't know
Lucia: 你在江苏是不是从来没逛过菜市场
Lucia: Have you never been to a market in Jiangsu?
Jake:菜市场逛过这种超市
Jake: I've been to markets, but not this kind of supermarket
Shure: 我就不信这没有桃汁吗
Shure: I can't believe there's no peach juice
Tasha: 菜市场送不送
Tasha: Do markets deliver?
Jake: 菜市场可以送
Jake: Markets can deliver
Jake: 超市不一定
Jake: Supermarkets, not necessarily
Alice:买吗
Alice: Should we buy it?
Tasha: 买吧 药 药是吗
Tasha: Buy it, medicine, right?
Shure: 没有真没有
Shure: No, really no
Alice:我再想想
Alice: Let me think again
Katrina:  桃汁没有我靠
Katrina: No peach juice, oh man
Alice:需要但是可以不用这么多
Alice: We need it, but not that much
Shure: 没有
Shure: No
Katrina:  受不了
Katrina: Can't handle this
Alice:但是几个人啊
Alice: But how many people are there?
Tasha: 我觉得蒜和葱就一个就行了呵呵
Tasha: I think one garlic and one green onion is enough, haha
Katrina:  怎么可能会没有桃汁
Katrina: How can there be no peach juice?
Tasha: 这要大葱吗
Tasha: Do we need big green onions?
Tasha: 还是小葱
Tasha: Or small green onions?
Alice: 姜可以不要哎
Alice: We can do without the ginger
Katrina:  哎这是葡萄汁吧
Katrina: Oh, is this grape juice?
Alice:蒜是出味的
Alice: Garlic for the flavor
Katrina: 我靠这也太大了
Katrina: Whoa, this is huge!
Jake:来让人过
Jake: Let them through.
Tasha: 行那那那就要着吧
Tasha: Alright, then let's take this.
Alice:哦不好意思
Alice: Oh, sorry.
Alice:看看加
Alice: Let's see...
Katrina:  这也有葡萄汁哦
Katrina: They have grape juice here too.
Alice:呃在哪呢
Alice: Uh, where is it?
Katrina: 我们拿的是什么啊
Katrina: What are we picking up?
Shure:  葡萄胡萝卜
Shure: Grapes and carrots.
Alice:蒜葱葱也用不了那么多呀
Alice: We don't need that much garlic and green onions.
Shure: 那把这放回去吧换这个
Shure: Then let's put these back and get this instead.
Tasha: 哎那明天有火锅的话
Tasha: Hey, if we're having hotpot tomorrow...
Katrina: 我们拿瓶小的
Katrina: Let's get a smaller bottle.
Tasha: 要不要买火锅底料和肉菜啊
Tasha: Should we buy hotpot base and some meat and veggies?
Katrina: 这个葡萄汁
Katrina: This grape juice.
Jake:他们买了底料
Jake: They bought the base.
Jake:肉他们好像没买
Jake: Looks like they didn't get meat.
Katrina: 这感觉很正宗啊
Katrina: This feels really authentic.
Tasha: 那要不要买肉
Tasha: Should we buy some meat?
Jake:可以买肉
Jake: We can buy meat.
Katrina: 很浓的葡萄感觉
Katrina: This grape flavor is really strong.
Jake: 回头对一下
Jake: Let's check it later.
Jake: 可以先
Jake: We can first...
Shure:  真没有桃汁啊
Shure: There's really no peach juice?
Alice:那个您好我们如果买的话会送葱姜蒜
Alice: Excuse me, if we buy, do we get free garlic, ginger, and green onions?
Katrina: 为什么呢
Katrina: Why?
Alice:送多少呢大概
Alice: How much do we get roughly?
Alice:就是消费
Alice: Just spend...
Alice:不会送吗不会送吗
Alice: Won't we get it? Won't we get it?
Katrina:  这个啊这椰奶也太大了
Katrina: This coconut milk is so big.
Tasha: 有的时候会员满9.9会送啊
Tasha: Sometimes members get it free if they spend 9.9.
Katrina: 这奶大吗
Katrina: Is this milk big?
Alice:没有没有被送过哎
Alice: Never got it for free.
Jake: 啊什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake: 我们还我们还满不了9.9
Jake: We haven't spent 9.9 yet.
Tasha: 呃主要是我们没有会员啊
Tasha: Uh, we don't have membership.
Alice:我好像有会员
Alice: I think I have membership.
Tasha: 你有吗不知道这今天会不会送
Tasha: You do? Not sure if they'll give it today.
Tasha: 有被送过
Tasha: Got it for free once.
Alice:有被送过但不一定是吧
Alice: Got it for free but not always, right?
Tasha: 他好像每天
Tasha: He seems to do it every day.
Alice:但是这也用不了这么多
Alice: But we don't need this much.
Tasha: 嗯没关系做火锅还要用的
Tasha: Hmm, it's fine. We can use it for hot pot.
Tasha: 拿着吧
Tasha: Just take it.
Alice:确实拿吧
Alice: Yeah, just take it.
Alice:你吃板栗仁吗
Alice: Do you eat chestnuts?
Alice: 可以放进去
Alice: We can add them in.
Tasha: 呃都可以
Tasha: Uh, sure, whatever.
Alice: 我怕他弄不熟
Alice: I'm worried they won't cook properly.
Tasha: 那算了吧
Tasha: Then forget it.
Alice:因为这个比较难煮
Alice: Because they're hard to cook.
Alice:不过也可以放进去提前煮一下
Alice: But we can also pre-cook them a bit first.
Alice:生的还是熟的
Alice: Raw or cooked?
Shure: 你好我回来了
Shure: Hi, I'm back.
Lucia: 放回去了吗已经
Lucia: Did you put it back already?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 没了吧 没了吗j人
Shure: Is it all gone? Is it?
Katrina:  没了
Katrina: Yeah, it's gone.
Tasha: 这里呢
Tasha: How about here?
Katrina:  那就找他们去
Katrina: Then let's go find them.
Shure:  走吧j人
Shure: Let's go then.
Alice: 放进去吧
Alice: Put it in.
Lucia: 限时买赠 买一送一
Lucia: Limited time offer, buy one get one free.
Jake:哎呀撞着了
Jake: Oh no, I bumped into you.
Lucia: 哎刚好碰到你们
Lucia: Oh, just happened to run into you guys.
Katrina:  买完了
Katrina: We finished shopping.
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys...
Katrina:  有两个没有
Katrina: There are two missing.
Katrina:  没有有两
Katrina: No, there are...
Katrina: 笔没有
Katrina: Pens are missing.
Alice:调料
Alice: Seasoning.
Jake: 买肉了吗
Jake: Did you buy meat?
Jake:火锅什么的他们要
Jake: For hot pot or whatever they need.
Katrina:  那去去买火锅的食材是吧
Katrina: So we need to buy hot pot ingredients, right?
Jake:那你们去吧
Jake: Then you guys go.
Alice:我们买葱蒜了
Alice: We bought onions and garlic.
Katrina:  啊葱蒜
Katrina: Ah, onions and garlic.
Katrina:  那我们去买火锅食材
Katrina: Then let's go buy hot pot ingredients.
Jake:肉在那去吧
Jake: The meat is over there, go ahead.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 好那那种什么肥牛卷啥的可以
Katrina: Okay, so those fatty beef rolls are okay.
Shure:  烤肉的也要买一下
Shure: We also need to buy some barbecue meat.
Tasha: 那我们的进度好慢啊他们都买完了
Tasha: Our progress is so slow, they've already finished shopping.
Jake:烤肉
Jake: Barbecue.
Katrina: 那个放冰箱应该可以放两天吧
Katrina: That should be fine in the fridge for two days, right?
Alice:我们比较分散呵呵
Alice: We're a bit scattered, haha.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure:  等下次好呃
Shure: Next time, uh...
Lucia: 呃一直得走那个牛卷
Lucia: Uh, we always need those beef rolls.
Shure:  先买火锅的食材
Shure: Let's buy the hotpot ingredients first.
Katrina: 哦对因为他不在
Katrina: Oh right, because he's not here.
Jake: 先火锅吧
Jake: Let's start with the hotpot.
Jake: 烤肉是要过一阵的
Jake: The barbecue is for later.
Katrina: 今晚不能吃啊
Katrina: We can't eat it tonight?
Jake:你你没炭呢还
Jake: You don't have any charcoal yet.
Alice:不对他们还在买火锅食材呢
Alice: No, they're still buying hotpot ingredients.
Jake: 他们还在买火锅
Jake: They're still buying hotpot.
Lucia: 应该可以吧放两天
Lucia: It should be fine for two days.
Shure:  这些都美团都可以送
Shure: These can all be delivered by Meituan.
Jake:一起嘛
Jake: Together.
Lucia: 放两天应该没事了
Lucia: Two days should be fine.
Lucia: 但如果我们烧烤是最后一天烤的话
Lucia: But if we do the barbecue on the last day...
Jake:那都美团送的
Jake: They all deliver through Meituan.
Alice:调味料在哪边呢
Alice: Where are the seasonings?
Lucia: 感觉不需要今天买
Lucia: Feels like we don't need to buy today.
Shure:  但是如的话可以先买
Shure: But if so, we can buy now.
Katrina: 不搞烧烤吧
Katrina: No barbecue, then?
Tasha: 你看那人聊天去了
Tasha: Look, he's chatting away.
Katrina: 他们不是说
Katrina: Didn't they say...
Jake:肉
Jake: Meat.
Jake:放得下不小冰箱
Jake: Can it fit in the small fridge?
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Tasha: 吃什么黑胡椒奥烧烤粉
Tasha: What about black pepper or barbecue powder?
Katrina: 就买买火锅的食材
Katrina: Just buy the hotpot ingredients.
Shure:  在这呢火锅的肉
Shure: Here's the hotpot meat.
Alice:在这吧但是这啊
Alice: Here, but this...
Jake:对对万对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, right.
Lucia: 烧烤的话最后一天才用
Lucia: We'll only need the barbecue stuff on the last day.
Alice:但是奥不是这是那种
Alice: But oh, not this kind.
Lucia: 咱中间应该还会再出来
Lucia: We should be able to come out again in between.
Alice:那是复合的那种
Alice: That's the mixed type.
Shure:  不咱自己偷偷吃不给他们吃
Shure: No, we'll eat it secretly ourselves and not give them any.
Katrina: 肉肉肉肉肉
Katrina: Meat, meat, meat, meat.
Alice:调味料调味料
Alice: Seasoning, seasoning.
Tasha: 调味料
Tasha: Seasoning.
Lucia: 趁着他们还没起床
Lucia: While they're still asleep.
Lucia: 先 先下楼烤两串
Lucia: Let's go downstairs and grill a few skewers first.
Alice:在这吧
Alice: Let's do it here.
Tasha: 就这么小个柜子
Tasha: Such a small cabinet.
Shure:  这是烤肉的吧
Shure: This is for grilling, right?
Alice:这不是略味鲜酱油
Alice: This isn't the tasty soy sauce.
Lucia: 日式烤肉片
Lucia: Japanese grilled meat slices.
Katrina: 这能
Katrina: This can...
Katrina: 火锅要找薄一点的
Katrina: For hotpot, we need thinner slices.
Alice:感觉调味料是不是应该在这呢
Alice: Shouldn't the seasoning be here?
Lucia: 这个应该是涮的
Lucia: This should be for shabu-shabu.
Alice:这是什么锅巴
Alice: What kind of crispy snack is this?
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on.
Katrina:  我有闹钟响了
Katrina: My alarm went off.
Katrina:  吓我一跳
Katrina: It startled me.
Lucia: 这到底是他们的longJackchen
Lucia: Is this really their longJackchen...
Lucia: 还是什么东西啊
Lucia: or something else?
Shure:  是这个吧
Shure: It's this one, right?
Shure:  我早上听得一清二楚
Shure: I heard it loud and clear this morning.
Alice: 这已经到熟食区了
Alice: We're already in the deli section.
Lucia: 真假
Lucia: Really?
Shure:  我就知道
Shure: I knew it.
Shure:  哪个倒霉蛋是闹钟自己没没醒
Shure: Which unlucky person didn't wake up to their alarm?
Shure:  因为那个真的特别不容易醒
Shure: Because it's really hard to wake up to that.
Shure:  我也不知道为什么
Shure: I don't know why either.
Katrina: 我要换一个
Katrina: I need to change it.
Katrina: 拿了一盒这个再拿一盒这个
Katrina: I grabbed a box of this and another box of that.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
Katrina:  这是上脑啊
Katrina: This is rib-eye, right?
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Tasha: 加碘哪 有人不能吃碘吗
Tasha: Iodized, can anyone not eat iodine?
Katrina:  上脑也是有肉吧
Katrina: Rib-eye has meat too, right?
Alice:盐来了
Alice: Salt is here.
Shure:  是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:碘
Alice: Iodine
Katrina: 他们没拿肉吗
Katrina: Didn't they take the meat?
Alice:没人不能吃碘吧
Alice: No one can't eat iodine, right?
Shure:  拿了两盒一样的
Shure: They took two boxes of the same.
Tasha: 那 那调温量
Tasha: Then, adjust the temperature.
Shure:  没有他们没拿
Shure: No, they didn't take it.
Katrina:  不一样
Katrina: It's different.
Shure: 嗯 OK
Shure: Hmm, OK.
Shure:  这个多少钱啊
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  35块9 那好便宜
Shure: 35.9 yuan, that's so cheap.
Alice:盐
Alice: Salt.
Katrina:  好贵啊
Katrina: So expensive.
Shure:  还好 35块9
Shure: It's okay, 35.9 yuan.
Katrina:  那可能这肉比较好吧
Katrina: Maybe this meat is better.
Alice:黑胡椒
Alice: Black pepper.
Shure:  换算换算过去50块钱一斤呗
Shure: If you convert it, it's 50 yuan per jin.
Shure:  对 50块钱正常价
Shure: Yeah, 50 yuan is the normal price.
Alice:那有没有白胡椒呢
Alice: Is there any white pepper?
Alice:有白胡椒吧
Alice: There should be white pepper, right?
Katrina:  那那那个
Katrina: Then, then...
Katrina:  吃火锅的话是不是还得买点蘸料
Katrina: For hot pot, we should get some dipping sauce, right?
Alice:辣椒粉
Alice: Chili powder.
Shure:  对蘸料他们应该去买
Shure: Yeah, they should go get the dipping sauce.
Alice:葱姜蒜
Alice: Green onions, ginger, garlic.
Shure:  咱们买牛肉羊肉
Shure: We'll buy beef and lamb.
Katrina:  以前那个什么海海底捞是不是可以送
Katrina: Didn't that place, Haidilao, deliver their dipping sauce?
Katrina: 他的那个蘸料过来
Katrina: They delivered their dipping sauce.
Alice:买葱姜蒜还是买葱姜蒜粉呢
Alice: Should we buy green onions, ginger, and garlic, or their powder?
Katrina:  算了还是自己弄哎
Katrina: Forget it, let's do it ourselves.
Tasha: 诶葱姜蒜粉好像可以啊
Tasha: Hey, green onion, ginger, and garlic powder might be good.
Katrina:  羊肉
Katrina: Lamb.
Katrina: 有羊肉吗
Katrina: Do they have lamb?
Tasha: 但是算了吧
Tasha: But forget it.
Tasha: 因为那个不是还要也要用
Tasha: Because you still need to use...
Katrina:  这都是肥牛啊
Katrina: This is all fatty beef.
Alice:糖你买了没
Alice: Did you buy sugar?
Tasha: 哦对糖在这呢
Tasha: Oh right, the sugar is here.
Alice:哦对
Alice: Oh right.
Alice:午餐肉还得
Alice: We still need luncheon meat.
Tasha: 我在想买
Tasha: I was thinking of buying.
Lucia: 这个便宜的还是买那个贵的
Lucia: Should we buy the cheaper one or the more expensive one?
Lucia: 这是煎这也是涮
Lucia: This one can be grilled, and this one can be boiled.
Jake:有啥差别吗这个糖
Jake: What's the difference with this sugar?
Tasha: 你看这5.9 这5.5
Tasha: Look, this one is 5.9, and this one is 5.5.
Alice:午餐肉需要
Alice: We need some luncheon meat.
Tasha: 好吧可是这个很绵这个很粗
Tasha: Okay, but this one is very fine and this one is coarse.
Jake: 我觉得这种比较正常
Jake: I think this type is more normal.
Jake:500 这个400克OK
Jake: 500 grams, this one is 400 grams, OK.
Lucia: 脆毛肚
Lucia: Crispy tripe.
Shure: 冷藏储存这个要
Shure: This one needs to be stored refrigerated.
Tasha: 算了就这个吧
Tasha: Forget it, let's go with this one.
Jake:就这个吧
Jake: Let's go with this one.
Katrina: 神奇
Katrina: Amazing.
Katrina: 可以放哎
Katrina: You can store it.
Shure: 咋这有冰箱
Shure: Why is there a refrigerator here?
Katrina: 这种东西有血
Katrina: This kind of thing has blood.
Jake:这个棉
Jake: This one is fine.
Tasha: 糖盐胡椒粉
Tasha: Sugar, salt, pepper.
Katrina: 可以放几天吗
Katrina: Can it be stored for a few days?
Katrina: 哦 5天
Katrina: Oh, five days.
Alice: 你得买绵白糖
Alice: You need to buy fine white sugar.
Katrina: 吊龙吊龙也好吃
Katrina: The hanging tender is also delicious.
Tasha: 买了绵白糖
Tasha: Bought fine white sugar.
Tasha: 糖盐胡椒粉味精味精是吧
Tasha: Sugar, salt, pepper, MSG, right?
Katrina: 但买了那个有没有虾滑哎
Katrina: But if we buy that, do we have shrimp paste?
Tasha: 你还要味精这呢
Tasha: You still want MSG, here it is.
Lucia: 我刚刚也想找虾滑
Lucia: I was just looking for shrimp paste too.
Katrina: 是吧我吃火锅必点虾滑
Katrina: Right? I must order shrimp paste when I have hot pot.
Alice:这是鸡精哦
Alice: This is chicken essence.
Shure: 拿着拿着
Shure: Take it, take it.
Alice:这个是味哦盐
Alice: This is flavor salt.
Tasha: 喂 您
Tasha: Hey, you.
Shure:  暴风吸入啊
Shure: Storm inhalation, huh?
Katrina:  哈哈哈爽了
Katrina: Hahaha, satisfying.
Shure:  爽
Shure: Satisfying.
Katrina:  羊肉是吗
Katrina: Is this lamb?
Alice:怎么是鸡精没有味精
Alice: Why is it chicken essence, not MSG?
Shure:  中间这些冰鲜柜应该有吧嗯
Shure: There should be some in the middle of these fresh food cabinets.
Tasha: 属实
Tasha: Definitely.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Shure:  这好像是豆制品类
Shure: This seems to be a type of soy product.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Shure:  看看有没有什么响铃之类的
Shure: Let's see if there's any ringing sound or something.
Shure:  那种没有可涮的
Shure: The kind that can't be rinsed.
没有
(No text)
Alice: 怎么没有味精呢
Alice: Why is there no MSG?
Lucia: 哎这有蒜蓉酱
Lucia: Hey, there's garlic sauce here.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure:  蒜蓉酱吃火锅用的到吗
Shure: Do we use garlic sauce for hotpot?
Katrina:  有的那个火锅店里他不是
Katrina: Some hotpot places...
Lucia: 就是你可以往蘸料里放
Lucia: You can put it in the dipping sauce.
Lucia: 但是咱们买这么一大瓶肯定用不完
Lucia: But we definitely won't use up such a big bottle.
Shure:  虾滑这呢
Shure: Here's the shrimp paste.
Katrina:  咱民宿有碗吗
Katrina: Do we have bowls at the Airbnb?
Katrina:  是不是我们的环保理念
Katrina: Is it part of our eco-friendly concept?
Lucia: 有
Lucia: Yes.
Katrina: 不允许用一次性的东西
Katrina: We don't use disposable items.
Alice:餐肉是不是也用不上那么多
Alice: We probably don't need that much luncheon meat either.
Tasha: 鸡精
Tasha: Chicken essence.
Lucia: 哦我们不拍到他就可以了
Lucia: Oh, as long as we don't film it, it's fine.
Tasha: 哦还是买了鸡精是吧没有味精是吧
Tasha: Oh, so we bought chicken essence instead of MSG, right?
Alice:没有没有味精
Alice: No, no MSG.
Shure:  我们刷碗的时候就
Shure: When we wash the dishes...
Alice:这差不多不过
Alice: That's about right, but...
Jake:没有味精
Jake: No MSG.
Tasha: 差不多味精和鸡精差不多
Tasha: MSG and chicken essence are about the same.
Shure:  我们直接卡掉
Shure: We'll just cut it off.
Shure:  吃完饭就卡掉了
Shure: Cut it off after we eat.
Alice:味精会健康一点
Alice: MSG is a bit healthier.
Shure:  然后把一次性的东西扔了
Shure: Then throw away the disposable stuff.
Shure:  但是我们吃饭的时候会拍
Shure: But we'll be filming while we eat.
Tasha: 把鸡精挑
Tasha: Pick out the chicken essence.
Alice:鸡精的添加剂多一点
Alice: Chicken essence has more additives.
Shure:  火锅旁边他肯定不敢拍
Shure: He definitely won't dare to film next to the hotpot.
Jake:哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:活到现在了
Jake: We've made it this far.
Lucia: 对因为有热气
Lucia: Yes, because of the steam.
Shure:  因为有热气
Shure: Because of the steam.
Shure:  对呃丸滑类的
Shure: Yeah, um, the meatballs and stuff.
Tasha: 金针菇松花蛋娃娃菜都买了
Tasha: We bought enoki mushrooms, century eggs, and baby cabbage.
Katrina: 哎没了
Katrina: Oh, that's it.
Alice: 我买过一个午餐肉
Alice: I bought some luncheon meat.
Shure: 这吶丸滑类的在那呢
Shure: The meatballs and stuff are over there.
Alice:但我不知道够不够
Alice: But I'm not sure if it's enough.
Katrina:  什么东西
Katrina: What is it?
Tasha: 草莓买了
Tasha: We bought strawberries.
Shure: 就是丸滑那些
Shure: It's just the meatballs and stuff.
Tasha: 奶油买了
Tasha: We bought cream.
Tasha: 薄荷保鲜膜
Tasha: And mint, plastic wrap.
Tasha: 蛋挞没买呢
Tasha: We haven't bought egg tarts yet.
Alice:谁买不买呢
Alice: Who's going to buy it?
Alice:放进去吧
Alice: Just put it in.
Shure:  这已经不在j人的
Shure: This isn't on J's list.
Shure:  清单了他现在很苦恼
Shure: He's really frustrated right now.
Shure:  这他妈的都不在我清单里
Shure: This stuff isn't on my list at all.
Alice:扔进去
Alice: Just throw it in.
Shure:  你们买什么
Shure: What are you guys buying?
Shure:  冻豆腐
Shure: Frozen tofu.
Shure:  豆制品拼盘
Shure: Tofu platter.
Katrina:  火锅拼盘
Katrina: Hot pot platter.
Tasha: 我已经开始渴了
Tasha: I'm already getting thirsty.
Tasha: 听到这个声音
Tasha: Just hearing this sound.
Jake: 买一会喝
Jake: We'll buy some to drink later.
Katrina: 这是什么黑千层
Katrina: What is this black mille-feuille?
Katrina: 这也是吃火锅用的
Katrina: Is this for hot pot too?
Tasha: 这买什么来着 咖啡豆
Tasha: What did we come here to buy again? Coffee beans.
Jake:喝
Jake: Drink.
Tasha: 他不知道
Tasha: He doesn't know.
Tasha: 磨咖啡要吗
Tasha: Do we need a coffee grinder?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Alice: 咖啡豆这不好买吧
Alice: Coffee beans are hard to find, right?
Tasha: 你好这里有咖啡豆卖吗
Tasha: Hi, do you have coffee beans here?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:看一下
Alice: Let's take a look.
Katrina:  他们是把食材任务全部交给我们了吗
Katrina: Did they leave all the ingredient shopping to us?
Katrina:  那不得考虑6人份吗
Katrina: Don't we have to consider portions for six people?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 不太确定他们买了什么呢
Lucia: Not sure what they bought though.
Katrina: 他们就跟我说他买了什么醋啊什么的
Katrina: They were just telling me what vinegar they bought and stuff.
Lucia: 是不是一会还能再偶遇一下
Lucia: Maybe we can run into them again later.
Alice:奶粉哦奶粉是他们买吧
Alice: Baby formula, did they buy that?
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Katrina:  那他们没买食品
Katrina: So they didn't buy any food.
Alice:奶粉是他们买吗
Alice: Did they buy the baby formula?
Alice:我们是几到几啊
Alice: What time are we meeting?
Shure:  素菜是不是交给他们了
Shure: Did they take care of the veggies?
Tasha: 我们是5-11
Tasha: We are from 5 to 11.
Katrina: 素菜
Katrina: Veggies.
Alice: 那我们没有买奶粉
Alice: So we didn't buy the baby formula.
Shure: 我们吃火锅吃素菜吗
Shure: Are we having veggies with hotpot?
Tasha: 没事其实奶粉不重要
Tasha: It's okay, baby formula isn't that important.
Katrina: 吃吃金针菇
Katrina: Let's have some enoki mushrooms.
Lucia: 吃一点
Lucia: Just a little bit.
Tasha: 我只想一小一小包而已
Tasha: I just want a small pack.
Shure:  绿叶菜是不吃是吗
Shure: We're not eating leafy greens, right?
Lucia: 我有时候会要个白菜或者油麦菜
Lucia: Sometimes I like to have some cabbage or lettuce.
Katrina: 感觉基本不吃吧
Katrina: I feel like we barely eat them.
Shure:  就是别人点会跟着吃两口
Shure: Yeah, we just nibble on them if others order.
Shure:  但自己不会主动点
Shure: But we don't order them ourselves.
Katrina:  一般点莴笋
Katrina: Usually, we order celtuce.
Jake:丑蛋糕他们在干嘛
Jake: What's the ugly cake crew doing?
Katrina:  笋呐什么
Katrina: Celtuce and stuff.
Lucia: 我也喜欢笋
Lucia: I like celtuce too.
Katrina: 对吧但绿叶菜你说什么
Katrina: Right? But leafy greens, what are you talking about?
Katrina: 小青菜没有小菠菜也没有小
Katrina: No baby bok choy, no baby spinach.
Alice:你在找啥呀
Alice: What are you looking for?
Tasha: 咖啡豆
Tasha: Coffee beans.
Katrina: 走吧逛玩玩
Katrina: Let's go for a walk and have some fun.
Alice:蓝胖子
Alice: Blue fatty.
Alice: 是蓝胖子吧
Alice: It's blue fatty, right?
Tasha: 啊太贵了这一罐没必要
Tasha: Ah, this can is too expensive, not worth it.
Jake:水果麦
Jake: Fruit wheat.
Alice: 哎有咖啡粉
Alice: Oh, there's coffee powder.
Katrina: 这还有一个冷藏过的
Katrina: There's also a refrigerated one here.
Katrina: 哈喽你们买那个肉制品
Katrina: Hello, did you guys buy any meat products?
Lucia: 呃哈喽
Lucia: Uh, hello.
Alice:这都有
Alice: They have everything here.
Tasha: 你觉得买哪个好
Tasha: Which one do you think we should buy?
Shure: hello
Katrina:  那个肉制品火锅全部就是我们管是吗
Katrina: So, we're in charge of all the meat products for the hotpot, right?
Tasha: 5 59
Alice:咖啡豆他是要干嘛
Alice: What's he going to do with the coffee beans?
Katrina: 那你们买了什么
Katrina: So, what did you guys buy?
Katrina:  青菜吗哎
Katrina: Vegetables, right?
Tasha: 他要磨咖
Tasha: He wants to grind coffee.
Jake:买了买了
Jake: We bought it, we bought it.
Alice:那这种是不是
Alice: Is this the kind?
Katrina: 好像没有买青菜
Katrina: It seems like we didn't buy any vegetables.
Tasha: 这是你要的咖啡豆吗
Tasha: Is this the coffee beans you wanted?
Jake:买了不多就买一个
Jake: We didn't buy much, just one.
Lucia: 还是多啊
Lucia: That's still a lot.
Alice: 还是这种的
Alice: It's still this kind.
Jake:这个今天是他们要做上汤娃娃菜
Jake: Today they're going to make baby cabbage in broth.
Shure:  我看了一眼其实不用买
Shure: I looked, we actually didn't need to buy it.
Jake: 专门给他上汤娃娃菜
Jake: Specifically for the baby cabbage in broth.
Jake:专门给他上汤娃娃菜搞的蔬菜
Jake: The vegetables are specifically for the baby cabbage in broth.
Tasha: 不用买
Tasha: No need to buy.
Shure:  就是这个有点捞
Shure: It's just that this is a bit much.
Jake:应该没有别的菜了
Jake: We probably don't have any other vegetables.
Katrina:  也就是说火锅下的菜跟
Katrina: So, the vegetables for the hotpot and...
Shure: 我不想买这个
Shure: I don't want to buy this.
Jake:火锅没有菜
Jake: The hotpot has no vegetables.
Jake:对火锅还没有菜
Jake: Yes, the hotpot still has no vegetables.
Tasha: 那你明天带吗
Tasha: Are you bringing it tomorrow?
Katrina: 肉质都是我们挑
Katrina: We're picking all the meat.
Shure: 给给你买的那个条条的那种
Shure: I got you the strips you wanted.
Katrina:  那我们得多加一点
Katrina: Then we need to add more.
Shure: 这种的 拿了一条这种的
Shure: This kind, I got a strip of this kind.
Katrina:  感觉6个人不够吃哎
Katrina: Feels like it's not enough for 6 people.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
这几份你们可以先看一下先
Take a look at these portions first.
Alice: 你买了吗
Alice: Did you buy it?
Shure: 我买了  啊 对
Shure: I bought it. Uh, yeah.
Lucia: 你可以先看一下吗
Lucia: Can you take a look first?
Tasha:这个吗 那行那我就不不拿了
Tasha: This one? Okay, then I won't take it.
Lucia: 现在买的东西
Lucia: The stuff you bought now...
Jake:好一会我们对一下吧
Jake: Let's check it later.
小微；那那
Tasha: Alright then.
Jake:盘算一下
Jake: Let's calculate it.
Jake:他们现在在套好
Jake: They are setting it up now.
Lucia: 好奇一下你们这边的东西
Lucia: Just curious about your stuff here.
Jake:他们在研究咖啡豆
Jake: They are studying coffee beans.
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film.
Alice:保鲜膜
Alice: Cling film.
Jake:咖啡豆
Jake: Coffee beans.
Lucia: 我们刚才好像是拿了一盒速溶咖啡
Lucia: We just grabbed a box of instant coffee, I think.
Shure:  我跟他跟他说了
Shure: I told him about it.
Jake:哦速溶但是这个就慢
Jake: Oh, instant coffee, but it's slow.
Lucia: 嗯？有泰拉
Lucia: Huh? There's Tera.
Katrina: 什么呀
Katrina: What is it?
Shure:  咖啡豆的话
Shure: If it's coffee beans...
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: It's this one.
Lucia: 好久不见了 从我回国
Lucia: Long time no see, since I returned to the country.
Katrina:  你们拿椰奶了吗
Katrina: Did you get coconut milk?
Alice:有椰子水
Alice: There's coconut water.
Shure:  购入一下
Shure: Let's purchase it.
Lucia: mitchposticks怎么还是从德国进口了
Lucia: Why is mitchposticks still imported from Germany?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 你们需要吗
Alice: Do you guys need it?
Katrina:  我在想
Katrina: I'm thinking.
Katrina:  咖啡是不是可以兑一点椰子汁啊
Katrina: Can we mix coffee with some coconut juice?
Katrina:  生椰拿铁
Katrina: Fresh coconut latte.
Alice:椰奶吗
Alice: Coconut milk?
Katrina:  嗯但是那种大的咖啡
Katrina: Yeah, but for that big coffee.
Shure: 可以
Shure: It works.
Katrina:  呃椰奶是不是只能放一天
Katrina: Uh, doesn't coconut milk only last for a day?
Alice:不开封的话可以放几天
Alice: If unopened, it can last a few days.
Katrina:  那就是开了那就得一天喝完呗
Katrina: So once opened, we have to finish it in a day.
Katrina:  我没看他那种小盒的椰树你知道吗
Katrina: I haven't seen those small packs of coconut milk, you know?
Katrina:  他都是大盒的椰树
Katrina: They're all large packs.
Jake:螺蛳粉看到了
Jake: Saw the snail noodles.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: That one.
Jake:真的
Jake: Really.
Katrina:  你去问一下子吧你拿
Katrina: Go ask about it, you take it.
Jake:我们要对一下吗
Jake: Should we verify it?
Lucia: 感觉可以
Lucia: Feels like we should.
Jake: 好那
Jake: Alright then.
Alice:其实那个大的你开封之后放两三天
Alice: Actually, after opening the big one, it lasts for two or three days.
Jake:那找个地方
Jake: Let's find a place.
Jake: 我们先对一下吧
Jake: Let's check it out first.
Katrina: 当时谁跟我说椰奶变质了会中毒
Katrina: Who told me that coconut milk would become toxic when it spoils?
Lucia: 对保鲜膜可以在超市买
Lucia: Yeah, you can buy plastic wrap at the supermarket.
Alice:确实
Alice: Definitely.
Jake:对一下我们找一个
Jake: Let's check it out and find one.
Katrina: 就不敢
Katrina: I just don't dare.
Alice:但是嗯嗯我一般一
Alice: But hmm, I usually...
Katrina: 我确实没有看见他那小盒小盒的
Katrina: I really didn't see those small boxes.
Alice:我一般买这种大的
Alice: I usually buy these big ones.
Tasha: 买咖啡液也行 就不用咖啡粉就不用速溶咖啡调了
Tasha: Buying coffee liquid is also fine. Then we don't need to use coffee powder or instant coffee.
Alice:之后放两三天也没事
Alice: After that, it can be kept for two or three days, no problem.
Alice: 不用他那个变质的话会很明显
Alice: If it spoils, it'll be very obvious.
Katrina: 要么直接叫外卖吧
Katrina: Or just order takeout.
Shure:  也行反正都都都行
Shure: That works too, anything's fine.
Katrina:  因为有两个东西买不到
Katrina: Because there are two things we can't buy.
Jake:都行都行反正我也不喝咖啡
Jake: Anything's fine, I don't drink coffee anyway.
Shure: 那你今天
Shure: So today you...
Jake:哈哈早上不行啊
Jake: Haha, not in the morning.
Katrina: 不知道以为我们工作呢
Katrina: People might think we're working.
Jake:早上喝了一下
Jake: I had some in the morning.
Katrina: 天天买这么多咖啡
Katrina: Buying this much coffee every day.
Shure: 不行了是吧
Shure: It's not good, right?
Jake:不行那要喝一下
Jake: It's not good, we need to drink less.
Lucia: 其实还好
Lucia: Actually, it's okay.
Shure:  我靠哥
Shure: Oh my god, brother.
Katrina: 这个肉不够吧
Katrina: Is this meat enough?
Jake:这两天应该就行了
Jake: It should be fine for the next two days.
Katrina:  如果我6个人吃火锅的话
Katrina: If six people are eating hot pot...
Jake:昨天也搞定了
Jake: We sorted it out yesterday.
Shure: 还行吧现在
Shure: It's okay now.
Jake:昨天拍破蛋搞定了
Jake: We handled the broken egg yesterday.
Alice:肉在哪啊
Alice: Where's the meat?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Jake:下面就是
Jake: It's below.
Katrina: 两盒牛肉
Katrina: Two boxes of beef.
Jake:执行就行
Jake: Just execute.
Tasha: 再买点丸子和虾滑
Tasha: Let's buy some more meatballs and shrimp paste.
Shure: 你身体还说得过去吗
Shure: How's your health holding up?
Katrina:  丸子买了虾滑也买了
Katrina: I already bought meatballs and shrimp paste.
Jake:强的很
Jake: Very strong
Katrina:  虾滑在这哦
Katrina: The shrimp paste is here
Shure: 真的吗 多久没体检了
Shure: Really? How long has it been since your last check-up?
Katrina:  我觉得还要拿两盒肉
Katrina: I think we should get two more boxes of meat
Katrina:  青菜也没买哎
Katrina: We didn't buy any vegetables either
Lucia: 我们为什么买哦
Lucia: Why did we buy it?
Lucia: 哦哦蔬菜是吧
Lucia: Oh, vegetables, right?
Lucia: 蔬菜哦新到的咸鱼土豆
Lucia: Vegetables, oh, the new salted fish potatoes
Katrina:  你要吃土豆是吗
Katrina: You want to eat potatoes, right?
Jake: 土豆好土豆可以
Jake: Potatoes are good, potatoes are fine
Jake:土豆可以啊
Jake: Potatoes are fine
Lucia: 其实我也喜欢
Lucia: Actually, I like them too
Katrina: 走吧那我们蔬菜买肉跟青菜
Katrina: Let's go then, we'll buy meat and vegetables
Jake:咱不是还有那个削土豆皮的那个
Jake: Don't we still have that potato peeler?
Tasha: 那个不是完了小土豆皮奥
Tasha: Didn't that one finish peeling small potatoes?
Tasha: 芋头没有买
Tasha: We didn't buy taro
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go
Shure: 芋头是啥啊
Shure: What's taro?
Lucia: 芋头放火锅吗
Lucia: Do you put taro in hotpot?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro
Tasha: 不是芋泥
Tasha: Not taro paste
Lucia: 啊okok
Lucia: Ah, ok ok
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste
Jake:哎呀这什么东西
Jake: Oh, what's this?
Lucia: sorry没有跟上这个频道
Lucia: Sorry, I didn't catch that
Shure: 芋泥
Shure: Taro paste
Katrina: 芋泥芋泥耶
Katrina: Taro paste, taro paste yay
Alice:芋头放火锅也很好吃
Alice: Taro in hotpot is also delicious
Alice: 那个荔浦芋头
Alice: The Lipu taro
Jake:酱香烤鸭
Jake: Sauce-flavored roast duck
Tasha: 对我是要买荔浦芋头
Tasha: Yes, I need to buy Lipu taro
Shure: 芋芋泥能波波吗
Shure: Can you Bobo with taro paste?
Tasha: 走吧诶不对
Tasha: Let's go, wait no
Tasha: 好那我们的爆皮刀就有两用了
Tasha: Okay, then our peeler has two uses
Shure:  芋泥能啵啵吗
Shure: Can you Bobo with taro paste?
Jake:哈哈哈走
Jake: Hahaha, let's go
Katrina: 哈哈少来这种
Katrina: Haha, stop it with that
Alice:可以
Alice: You can
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Alice:咋了
Alice: What happened?
Tasha: 你想吃螺蛳粉吗
Tasha: Do you want to eat Luosifen?
Katrina:  咦恶心
Katrina: Eww, gross.
Tasha: 你喜欢吃吗
Tasha: Do you like it?
Jake: 吃什么呀
Jake: What are we eating?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This.
Jake: 螺蛳粉啊
Jake: Luosifen, huh?
Jake:嗯呃能吃就没
Jake: Hmm, if we can eat it, then okay.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Jake: 那么没一定要吃
Jake: Then we don't have to eat it.
Lucia: 水产品
Lucia: Seafood.
Jake: 对没那么想吃
Jake: Yeah, not really feeling it.
Jake:doyouknow
Jake: Do you know?
Lucia: 如果我们想买虾仁的话
Lucia: If we want to buy shrimp.
Alice:牵手手我们去买蔬菜吧
Alice: Let's hold hands and go buy vegetables.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake:没得吃可以吃一吃
Jake: If there's nothing else, we can eat a bit.
Jake: 可以吃一吃
Jake: We can eat a bit.
Katrina: 水产品还是算了吧
Katrina: Seafood, let's skip it.
Tasha: 谁去买蔬菜他们去买蔬菜
Tasha: Who’s buying vegetables? They’re buying vegetables.
Alice:我们啊
Alice: We are.
Jake:他们他们买蔬菜
Jake: They, they’re buying vegetables.
Alice:他们买过了吗
Alice: Did they buy it already?
Jake:他们买蔬菜
Jake: They’re buying vegetables.
Alice:我们菜不是在那边吗
Alice: Aren’t our vegetables over there?
Jake:我我对啊你们他们
Jake: I... I... Yeah, you guys, they...
Tasha: 他们可能先买肉吧
Tasha: Maybe they’ll buy meat first.
Jake: 他们买帝王蟹是吧
Jake: They’re buying king crabs, right?
Tasha: 这个也在资金范围内吗
Tasha: Is that within budget?
Jake:你们买海蟹
Jake: You’re buying sea crabs.
Jake:哈哈不不你们买海鲜吗
Jake: Haha, no, no, you’re buying seafood?
Lucia: 哇哦 我可以吃这个吗
Lucia: Wow, can I eat this?
Jake: 哈哈哈打打招呼吧
Jake: Haha, let’s say hi.
Katrina: 我们的预算可以吃这个吗
Katrina: Is our budget enough for this?
Jake: 要不就拍一拍吧要不
Jake: How about we just take a picture?
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello.
Katrina: 2099
Katrina: 2099.
Lucia: 扫描一下
Lucia: Scan it.
Jake: 1,699也还行吧
Jake: 1,699 is okay, right?
Alice:您好
Alice: Hello.
Tasha: 那来一只吧
Tasha: Then let’s get one.
Lucia: 真的吗可以吃吗
Lucia: Really? Can we eat it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈来一只吧
Lucia: Hahaha, let's get one.
Shure:  你千万不要口嗨
Shure: You better not just talk big.
Shure:  我们会当真的好不好
Shure: We'll take it seriously, okay?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:我就说也还行
Jake: I was just saying it's not bad.
Jake:我没多说什么
Jake: I didn't say much more.
Tasha: 有没有那个转架还是干嘛
Tasha: Do we have that rotisserie or what?
Jake:哈哈哈我没哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, I didn't hahaha.
Lucia: 也还行我们就把这个野字去掉吧啊
Lucia: It's not bad, let's just remove the word "wild."
Lucia: 把还字也去掉
Lucia: And remove the word "not."
Shure: 蘸料你们买了吗
Shure: Did you guys buy any dipping sauce?
Lucia: 对对对我们自动识别成型
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, we automatically recognize the shape.
Alice:我们去找一下荔荔浦芋头吧
Alice: Let's go find some Lili Pu taro.
Alice:但我觉得不一定有
Alice: But I think it might not be available.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  蘸料你们买了吗
Shure: Did you buy the dipping sauce?
Shure: 火锅的蘸料 那一起去买一点
Shure: For hotpot dipping sauce, let's go buy some together.
Alice:蘸料没有
Alice: No dipping sauce.
Lucia: 没有买蘸料
Lucia: We didn't buy any dipping sauce.
Shure:  你们都吃什么碟的火锅一般
Shure: What kind of dipping sauce do you usually use for hotpot?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Tasha: 我要醋
Tasha: I want vinegar.
Shure: 麻酱醋麻酱
Shure: Sesame paste, vinegar, sesame paste.
Lucia: 芝麻酱
Lucia: Sesame paste.
Lucia: 你吃什么
Lucia: What do you eat?
Lucia: 找到了啥呀
Lucia: What did you find?
Tasha: 你吃什么碟呢 醋碟
Tasha: What dipping sauce do you use? Vinegar sauce?
Shure:  白灼汁
Shure: Boiled sauce.
Shure:  你吃火锅一般吃什么蘸料
Shure: What dipping sauce do you usually use for hotpot?
Alice:麻酱
Alice: Sesame paste.
Katrina: 我醋
Katrina: I want vinegar.
Jake:呃麻酱吧
Jake: Uh, sesame paste, I guess.
Alice: 油碟
Alice: Oil sauce.
Shure:  你要你要醋
Shure: You want vinegar?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Jake:你吃什么碟
Jake: What dipping sauce do you use?
Tasha: 你背叛了江苏人
Tasha: You betrayed Jiangsu people.
Lucia: 那我们现在醋和麻酱还有什么别的需要吗
Lucia: So we have vinegar and sesame paste now. Do we need anything else?
Jake:其实我在江苏都没怎么吃过火锅
Jake: Actually, I haven't eaten much hotpot in Jiangsu.
Jake:我都是上了大学才
Jake: I only learned about it after I went to college.
Katrina: 醋啊香菜
Katrina: Vinegar and cilantro...
Shure: 都是周周边
Shure: It's all around.
Lucia: 湘菜哈哈哈
Lucia: Hunan cuisine, haha.
Jake:你是醋碟吗
Jake: Are you a vinegar dish?
Lucia: 没事我们可以切一些香菜然后
Lucia: No worries, we can chop some cilantro and...
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Lucia: 吃香菜的同学吃不吃香菜的同学不吃
Lucia: Those who eat cilantro can eat it, and those who don't, won't.
Tasha: 我们不应该都和喝恒硕香醋长大的吗
Tasha: Didn't we all grow up drinking Hengshuo vinegar?
Katrina: 看有没有小瓶醋啊
Katrina: See if there's a small bottle of vinegar.
Shure:  杨老板吃什么
Shure: What does Jake eat?
Jake:呃就麻将吧
Jake: Uh, just sesame paste.
Katrina: 大瓶醋
Katrina: Big bottle of vinegar.
Lucia: 对我觉得麻酱其实也可以买小瓶
Lucia: Yeah, I think sesame paste can also come in small bottles.
Lucia: 嗯感觉不是很用的完的样子
Lucia: Hmm, it seems like we can't finish it all.
Jake:或者当回江苏人吧
Jake: Or we could be Jiangsu people for a day.
Jake:要不吃醋碟也行
Jake: Or just eat vinegar dishes.
Katrina: 用不完多吃两顿火锅
Katrina: If we can't finish, just have hotpot for two more meals.
Alice:这是熟食了
Alice: This is cooked food.
Tasha: 对应该在那吧
Tasha: Right, it should be there.
Lucia: 也可以其实火锅还挺省钱的
Lucia: Hotpot can actually save money.
Lucia: 嗯只要一堆食材往里一煮就好了哈
Lucia: Hmm, you just throw a bunch of ingredients in and cook it, haha.
Jake: 对是的粽子也很省钱哈哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, it is. Zongzi also saves money, hahaha.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Jake: 买点方便面吧
Jake: Let's buy some instant noodles.
Jake: 算了算了哈哈哈
Jake: Forget it, forget it, hahaha.
Katrina:  后面两天经费不足
Katrina: Budget's tight for the next two days.
Katrina:  天天方便面
Katrina: Instant noodles every day.
Tasha: 你觉得芋头会在哪有呢
Tasha: Where do you think we can find taro?
Alice:芋头
Alice: Taro.
Katrina: 找到醋了吗
Katrina: Did you find the vinegar?
Jake:干啥去啦
Jake: Where did you go?
Alice:问一下那个啥吧
Alice: Just ask about it.
Shure: 没找到反正
Shure: Couldn't find it anyway.
Alice: 刚没看见反正
Alice: Didn't see it anyway.
Shure:  你好调料的那些在哪里
Shure: Excuse me, where are the condiments?
Shure:  蘸料啊好嘞
Shure: Dipping sauces? Got it.
Katrina:  前边右边
Katrina: Ahead, to the right.
Alice: 这种是不是也可以涮火锅
Alice: Can this also be used for hotpot?
Alice:这种魔芋之类的
Alice: This kind of konjac and such.
Tasha: 啊对豆豆制品
Tasha: Ah, right, soy products.
Tasha: 但是他们会不会买豆制品呢
Tasha: But will they buy soy products?
Alice: 不知道那
Alice: No idea.
Tasha: 那那那我觉得要来一个豆腐
Tasha: Well, well, I think we should get some tofu.
Katrina:  这是韩国的那种烧酒对吗
Katrina: Is this the Korean soju?
Alice: 我需要魔芋
Alice: I need konjac.
Lucia: 唉我们要买粉吗
Lucia: Hey, should we buy vermicelli?
Tasha: 你喜欢吃这种干豆腐还是吃
Tasha: Do you like to eat this kind of dried tofu or...
Katrina: 呵呵我妈很喜欢火锅里下粉丝哦
Katrina: Haha, my mom loves adding vermicelli to hotpot.
Alice:内酯豆腐
Alice: Silken tofu.
Tasha: 内酯豆腐
Tasha: Silken tofu.
Tasha: 这个呢浆水豆腐哎
Tasha: And this one, fermented tofu.
Lucia: 这个保鲜膜他们买了吗一次性手套
Lucia: Did they buy cling film and disposable gloves?
Jake:这都什么差别
Jake: What's the difference?
Jake: 这个这个一般
Jake: This one is average.
Jake:我感觉这个有点硬
Jake: I feel this one is a bit hard.
Katrina: 好像没听到他们买
Katrina: Seems like they didn't buy it.
Alice:就是那种老豆腐
Alice: It's the old-fashioned tofu.
Tasha: 那就这种吧
Tasha: Then let's go with this one.
Jake:啊可以
Jake: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 保鲜膜刚才他们买了吗
Lucia: Did they just buy cling film?
Jake:看起来不错
Jake: Looks good.
Tasha: 鲜豆腐 豆腐皮呢
Tasha: Fresh tofu. What about tofu skin?
Lucia:如果没有的话我觉得咱们可以拿一个
Lucia: If not, I think we should get one.
Alice:魔芋你要吃那种
Alice: Do you want that kind of konjac?
Katrina:  可以拿一个
Katrina: We can get one.
Katrina:  然后在结账的地方发现买了再放
Katrina: And if we find out they bought it, we can put it back at the checkout.
Tasha: 魔芋
Tasha: Konjac.
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Katrina: 再放回去吗
Katrina: Then put it back?
Tasha: 这个魔芋好奇怪
Tasha: This konjac is weird.
Lucia: 也可以要哪种
Lucia: You can choose which type.
Lucia: 有加厚是这种普通的啊
Lucia: There's the thicker one or the regular one.
Alice:这魔芋就是这种的
Alice: This konjac is just like that.
Lucia: 点段式免刀撕
Lucia: Perforated, tearable without a knife.
Tasha: 有没有魔芋丝
Tasha: Do they have konjac strips?
Lucia: 还有这种
Lucia: There's also this type.
Alice:魔芋丝
Alice: Konjac strips.
Tasha: 魔芋丝魔芋丝或者魔芋皮都行
Tasha: Konjac strips or konjac skin, both are fine.
Shure: 没有更小一点的醋类
Shure: Don't they have smaller vinegar bottles?
Lucia: 底下好像是保鲜袋
Lucia: It looks like there are some fresh-keeping bags underneath.
Lucia: 咱还剩保鲜膜
Lucia: We still have some cling wrap left.
Shure:  醋只有这么大的了
Shure: There's only this much vinegar left.
Tasha: 行吧
Tasha: Alright then.
Alice: 就这几种
Shure:  平时会当饮料喝吗
Shure: Do you usually drink it like a beverage?
Alice:买这种吧
Alice: Let's buy this one.
Alice:这种比较原生
Alice: This one is more natural.
Lucia: 我不会我
Lucia: I won't, I...
Tasha: 行那再拿个这个吧
Tasha: Okay, let's get this one too.
Shure: 可恶 居然没有山西的人
Shure: Damn, there's no one from Shanxi here.
Lucia: 不过醋确实一般只有这个大瓶
Lucia: But vinegar usually only comes in this big bottle.
Alice:3块9可以
Alice: 3.9 yuan is fine.
Lucia: 小瓶的太难找了
Lucia: The small bottles are really hard to find.
Shure:  买麻酱
Shure: Get some sesame paste.
Shure:  你平时不蘸麻酱啊
Shure: You don't usually dip in sesame paste?
Katrina: 我不蘸
Katrina: I don't dip.
Alice: 买这个金针菇吧这个便宜
Alice: Let's buy these enoki mushrooms, they're cheap.
Katrina:  我是那湖南口味
Katrina: I'm into Hunan flavors.
Katrina:  酸辣口味
Katrina: Sour and spicy.
Alice:: 呃把这个有机的给它放回去
Alice: Uh, put this organic one back.
Katrina: 我尝了
Katrina: I tried it.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Jake: 咱就不要那么有机了
Jake: Let's not go so organic.
Katrina: 我不是来几次北京我吃那麻酱涮肉吗
Katrina: When I came to Beijing a few times, I had sesame paste with the hot pot.
Katrina:  不下饭
Katrina: Not appetizing.
Alice: 这有娃娃菜吗
Alice: Is there any baby bok choy here?
Alice: 让我找找
Alice: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  就是我发现南北最大的明显
Katrina: The biggest difference between the north and south...
Jake:哎你问的好
Jake: Good question.
Katrina: 最大的差别就是吃不吃麻酱
Katrina: The biggest difference is whether you eat sesame paste or not.
Alice:没有
Alice: There's none.
Katrina:  我那山东舍友也吃麻酱
Katrina: My roommate from Shandong eats sesame paste too.
Lucia:这个是什么呀
Lucia: What is this?
Katrina:  然后我们其他几个舍友都是四川
Katrina: And the rest of us are from Sichuan.
Katrina:  江西的就孤立他
Katrina: We isolated the one from Jiangxi.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Like...
Katrina:  你知道我们那鸳鸯锅就中间这么小
Katrina: You know, our ying-yang pot has a small section in the middle.
Katrina:  是那个清清汤
Katrina: It's a clear broth.
Shure: 清汤
Shure: Clear broth.
Lucia: 哎同志们
Lucia: Hey everyone
Lucia: 这里有这个海底捞花生芝麻酱蘸料啊
Lucia: Here’s the Haidilao peanut sesame sauce dip
Shure: 啊对对对直接拿那个
Shure: Ah, yeah, yeah, just grab that one
Lucia: 我们是不是可以买两两3包这个
Lucia: Should we buy two or three packs of this?
Lucia: 嗯嗯会小一些吧感觉
Lucia: Hmm, it might be a bit smaller, I think
Lucia: 说不定买3包就跟买一瓶价格差不多
Lucia: Maybe buying three packs is about the same price as one bottle
Tasha: 我找到了芋头
Tasha: I found taro
Tasha: 但是不是荔浦芋头咋办
Tasha: But it’s not Lipu taro, what do we do?
Katrina: 不浪费嘛
Katrina: Don’t waste it
Katrina: 我们环保一点
Katrina: Let’s be more eco-friendly
Alice:不是荔浦芋头
Alice: It’s not Lipu taro
Shure: 这是需要泄的还是什么
Shure: Does it need to be diluted or what?
Alice: 打出来的不细腻
Alice: It’s not smooth when blended
Katrina: 香菇酱也行哎
Katrina: Mushroom sauce would work too
Lucia: 什么叫泄
Lucia: What do you mean by diluted?
Katrina: 直接挤出来就能蘸吧
Katrina: Just squeeze it out and dip it
Alice:是那个味道
Alice: That’s the taste
Shure: 啊不是不是稠的那种
Shure: Ah, no, it’s not the thick type
Alice: 这种芋头
Alice: This kind of taro
Alice:嗯只只适合那个啥
Alice: Hmm, it’s only good for certain things
Shure: 然后需要卸一下
Shure: Then it needs to be diluted
Lucia: 卸什么意思
Lucia: What do you mean by diluted?
Shure:  就是拿水
Shure: Just with water
Katrina: 就是你你在火锅店吃那个是卸过的
Katrina: You know, the ones you eat at hotpot places are diluted
Alice:问一下吧
Alice: Let’s ask about it
Tasha: 吃烤地瓜吗
Tasha: Want some roasted sweet potato?
Alice:没有烤箱是吧
Alice: We don’t have an oven, right?
Alice: 也可以
Alice: That works too
Katrina: 卸是什么啊
Katrina: What is diluted?
Alice: 买那种烟薯
Alice: Buy those smoked sweet potatoes
Katrina: 稀释
Katrina: Thin it out
Tasha: 我也这么觉得吧
Tasha: I think so too
Alice: 这种板栗的也可以
Alice: This chestnut one is fine too
Tasha: 嗯但这种吃起来有点沙
Tasha: Hmm, but this one’s a bit mealy
Alice: 都挺好吃的
Alice: They’re all pretty tasty
Lucia: 这里还有油碟
Lucia: There’s also oil dip here
Tasha: 我想哎
Tasha: I want it
Tasha: 烟薯地瓜
Tasha: Smoked sweet potatoes
Tasha: 这个可以
Tasha: This one’s good
Tasha: 你觉得买几个
Tasha: How many do you think we should buy?
Katrina: 拿一罐吧
Katrina: Let's just get one can.
Alice:至少至少买一个大的吧
Alice: At least get a big one.
Katrina: 他们两个女生
Katrina: There are two girls.
Alice: 这个小的
Alice: This small one.
Tasha: 他们这种大的可以切小一点
Tasha: The big ones can be cut into smaller pieces.
Tasha: 买这个吧
Tasha: Let's buy this one.
Alice:一大包的
Alice: A big pack.
Katrina: 哪的呀
Katrina: Where's it from?
Alice:小一点的
Alice: The smaller ones.
Tasha: 这个这种的好熟
Tasha: These ones look well-cooked.
Shure: 问了都是吃醋和吃香菜
Shure: They asked if it's with vinegar or cilantro.
Katrina: 就一个是海南的
Katrina: There's one from Hainan.
Tasha:蜜薯也可以
Tasha: Sweet potatoes are also good.
Lucia: 他是家在海南吗
Lucia: Does he live in Hainan?
Alice:蜜薯更甜
Alice: Sweet potatoes are sweeter.
Lucia: 他在海南上学是不是
Lucia: Does he go to school in Hainan?
Alice:哦两个都挺好吃的
Alice: Oh, both are pretty tasty.
Katrina: 对他好像是在海南上学
Katrina: Yeah, I think he studies in Hainan.
Alice: 不一样的好吃
Alice: They taste differently good.
Shure: 不是吃醋就是吃芝麻酱
Shure: It's either vinegar or sesame sauce.
Tasha: 我觉得蜜薯好吃点吧
Tasha: I think sweet potatoes are tastier.
Katrina:  好那就分为两大流派
Katrina: Okay, then let's split into two main groups.
Shure:  走没了吧
Shure: Alright, let's go.
Katrina:  拿两盒肉
Katrina: Grab two boxes of meat.
Alice: 葱姜蒜组合
Alice: The green onion, ginger, and garlic combo.
Katrina: 肉不够啊
Katrina: There's not enough meat.
Lucia: 肉不够啊
Lucia: There's not enough meat.
Katrina: 调料差不多
Katrina: We have enough spices.
Lucia: 咱们6个人
Lucia: We have six people.
Lucia: 都在咱们这里拿着
Lucia: We're all carrying stuff here.
Tasha: 有荔浦芋头吗
Tasha: Do they have Lipu taro?
Katrina: 我看他们买了葱
Katrina: I saw they bought some green onions.
Alice: 大的芋头
Alice: The big taro.
Alice:啊那种也可以
Alice: Ah, that kind is fine too.
Katrina:  香菜肯定没买呀
Katrina: They definitely didn't buy cilantro.
Alice:可以可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure, sure.
Alice: 冻一下子更粉
Alice: Freeze it a bit and it gets softer.
Katrina:  我不敢吃这玩意啊
Katrina: I don't dare to eat that stuff.
Tasha: 我觉得还冻一下子冻一下还懒得切了
Tasha: I think freezing it makes it easier to cut.
Alice:冻一下子更好吃
Shure:  觉得可怕
Katrina: 是是挺可怕的呀
Tasha: 是吗没关系我主要在这个
Katrina: 感觉他的脑袋一口
Shure:  完了跟丢了去搜寻吧
Tasha: 就没看到没削皮的
Katrina: 一口爆汁那脑袋
Shure:  巡回猎犬
Alice: 荔浦芋头
Katrina:  又去那个拿肉哎
Katrina:  好像确实没买羊肉哈
Tasha:那人呢车呢
Katrina:  都是牛肉
Shure:  对咱没买羊肉
Alice:没事待会再偶遇吧
Shure:  都是羊肉的
Katrina:  但是那个柜子里好像也都是牛肉
Lucia: 对基本都是牛肉哎
Alice:诶 那你荔浦芋头要做芋圆吗
Tasha: 对芋呃芋泥
Tasha: Oh, taro mash.
Alice: 那你要做芋圆吗
Alice: Are you making taro balls?
Alice:我可以帮你揉
Alice: I can help you knead it.
Alice:我特别喜欢揉的那个
Alice: I really like kneading.
Tasha: 哈哈小心点
Tasha: Haha, be careful.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Got it.
Alice:然后那个荔浦芋头也可以涮火锅
Alice: And you can also use Lipu taro for hotpot.
Tasha: 嗯可以啊
Tasha: Yeah, we can.
Alice:如果我们能买的话
Alice: If we can buy it.
Alice: 买个大块的也可以
Alice: We can buy a big piece too.
Tasha: 可以买两个大块的
Tasha: We can buy two big pieces.
Alice:没事如果红红薯吃不完的话
Alice: No worries, if we can't finish the sweet potatoes...
Alice:做成红薯芋啊
Alice: ...make sweet potato taro.
Katrina: 我们在这拿两个
Katrina: We'll take two from here.
Lucia: 我们在这吃
Lucia: We'll eat here.
Alice: 不是有那个紫薯粉吗
Alice: Don't we have purple sweet potato powder?
Tasha: 紫薯粉是用来加颜色的
Tasha: The purple sweet potato powder is for adding color.
Katrina:  上次我去广东那边玩
Katrina: Last time I went to Guangdong...
Katrina: 我看他们吃那个吊龙
Katrina: ...I saw them eating hanging dragon.
Tasha: 他们去干啥去了
Tasha: What were they doing?
Alice:就这个荔浦芋头没什么颜色
Alice: This Lipu taro has no color.
Jake:找你们去了
Jake: I was looking for you guys.
Katrina: 吊龙好像还可以
Katrina: The hanging tender seems fine.
Tasha: 烤地瓜吗
Tasha: Are we roasting sweet potatoes?
Lucia: 什么叫吊
Lucia: What do you mean by hanging?
Katrina:  烤什么叫叫地瓜
Katrina: What do you mean by roasting sweet potatoes?
Jake:烤就放烤箱
Jake: For roasting, just use the oven.
Katrina: 是一种牛的一个部位
Katrina: It's a part of the cow.
Alice: 放吧另一个呢
Alice: Go ahead, what about the other one?
Tasha: 另什么另一个
Tasha: What other one?
Jake:放烤箱是吧
Jake: Put it in the oven, right?
Katrina: 不是吃那个潮汕牛肉火锅吗
Katrina: Aren't we having Chaoshan beef hotpot?
Tasha: 噢噢烟薯是吗
Tasha: Oh, oh, smoke yam, right?
Katrina: 他每一个都划的很细致
Katrina: He slices each one so meticulously.
Jake:土豆
Jake: Potatoes.
Tasha: 好吧我想吃
Tasha: Alright, I want to eat.
Jake: 有土豆吗
Jake: Do we have potatoes?
Katrina: 再拿一盒吊龙
Katrina: Get another box of hanging tender.
Jake: 我不用我不用
Jake: I don't need it, I don't need it.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I was just kidding.
Jake:因为刚刚不是提到了吗
Jake: Because it was just mentioned.
Katrina: 再去拿拿羊
Katrina: Go get some lamb too.
Shure:  我找到了
Shure: I found it.
Alice:啊有的有的
Alice: Ah, yes, we have it.
Lucia: 什么
Lucia: What?
Shure:  我刚才买了一啊
Shure: I just bought one.
Shure:  这是牛肉丸啊
Shure: This is beef balls.
Katrina: 够了 5盒肉
Katrina: Enough, 5 boxes of meat.
Shure:  够了够了
Shure: That's enough, that's enough.
Katrina: 五六盒肉
Katrina: Five or six boxes of meat.
Shure:   1盒两盒3盒4盒5盒5盒肉
Shure: 1 box, 2 boxes, 3 boxes, 4 boxes, 5 boxes, 5 boxes of meat.
Alice:两个
Alice: Two.
Jake:给你加俩土豆
Jake: I'll add two potatoes for you.
Katrina:  还有虾滑两盒
Katrina: And two boxes of shrimp paste.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Katrina: 两盒牛肚
Katrina: Two boxes of beef tripe.
Tasha: 你只要爱吃土豆对你就可以加入
Tasha: As long as you love potatoes, you can join us.
Katrina: 够了
Katrina: That's enough.
Katrina: 就青青菜没买
Katrina: We didn't buy any greens.
Tasha: 申请加入我们土门
Tasha: Apply to join our potato club.
Katrina: 就吃豆制品
Katrina: Just eat soy products.
Jake:你是土豆
Jake: You are a potato.
Tasha: 呃只需要交298元一年
Tasha: Uh, you only need to pay 298 yuan a year.
那就吃豆制品呗
Speaker: Then just eat soy products.
Jake:为啥这是什么门
Jake: Why? What is this door?
Katrina: 叫什么金针菇那种
Katrina: It's called enoki mushrooms or something.
Alice:会员费
Alice: Membership fee.
Jake:每天都可以吃土豆吗
Jake: Can you eat potatoes every day?
Jake:呃有什么
Jake: Uh, what is there?
Lucia: 青菜我投一票是
Lucia: Green veggies, I vote for them.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 只要看见我就可以吃
Tasha: As long as you see me, you can eat.
Lucia: 生菜好了还有人想吃
Lucia: Lettuce is fine, does anyone want it?
Katrina:  还有人想吃土豆夹子啊
Katrina: Does anyone want potato sandwiches?
Katrina: 可以啊你买呗
Katrina: Sure, go buy it.
Jake:土豆夹子哦
Jake: Potato sandwiches, huh.
Tasha: 你跟他们说我们买了土豆
Tasha: Tell them we bought potatoes.
Tasha: 还有豆制品豆腐什么
Tasha: And soy products, tofu and stuff.
Tasha: 豆腐的都买了
Tasha: We bought all the tofu.
Katrina: 那我们把豆制品要放了吗
Katrina: So, should we put the soy products away?
Alice: 买了魔芋
Alice: We bought konjac.
Lucia: 我们也买了豆腐好像
Lucia: We also bought tofu, I think.
Alice:买了什么豆腐
Alice: What kind of tofu did we buy?
Shure:  豆腐什么
Shure: Tofu, what?
Shure:  4拼这种豆制品拼盘
Shure: A four-variety tofu platter.
Alice:哦不一样的东西
Alice: Oh, different stuff.
Katrina: 你这个你这个是做什么的啊
Katrina: What is this for?
Tasha: 你这个是干的
Tasha: Yours is dried.
Tasha: 这是鲜的啊
Tasha: This is fresh.
Katrina: 就是放火锅里吃吗
Katrina: Is it for hotpot?
Tasha: 鲜豆腐
Tasha: Fresh tofu.